♪♪♪
Tyra: "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
IS NOT JUST ABOUT BEAUTY.
IT'S A JOURNEY
OF TRANSFORMATION,
AND OUR WINNERS HAVE
TRANSFORMED INTO WORKING MODELS
THAT ARE WORKING.
NOW A NEW JOURNEY WILL BEGIN.
32 GIRLS
WITH TOP MODEL POTENTIAL
WERE CHOSEN
FROM THOUSANDS OF APPLICANTS.
I AM AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Tyra: AND WILL COMPETE
FOR A CHANCE TO BE CUT,
CHALLENGED--
OH, OH, OH!
Tyra: AND COACHED BY THE BEST.
I NEED HIGH FASHION,
LIKE BAM!
(cheers)
SO, LADIES,
WELCOME TO RUNWAY 101.
YOU BETTER GIVE IT TO ME!
YOU HAVE NOT SEEN DIVA YET.
CHIN UP FOR ME, SWEETIE.
BOOM.
Tyra: WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
THE COMPETITION STARTS NOW.
♪♪♪
MY NAME'S SARA.
I'VE NEVER DONE ANY MODELING
OR ANYTHING,
BUT I STILL HAVE A GOOD SHOT
AT IT, MAYBE.
(laughs)
MY NAME IS DANIELLE.
I NEED TO GET IN THAT HOUSE,
AND I'M NOT GONNA REST,
AND I'M NOT GONNA STOP
UNTIL I DO THAT.
♪♪♪
MY NAME IS DANI,
AND I WANT TO BE A MODEL.
MY ENTIRE LIFE HAS BEEN A DREAM.
I CHEERLEAD AT FOOTBALL GAMES,
AND I HAVE SO MANY FRIENDS.
I'M SO EXCITED!
I'M LIKE...
I KNOW!
LIKE, I REMEMBER HER!
6'1" GIRL.
IT WAS ACTUALLY
MY FIRST TIME ON AN AIRPLANE.
COMING HERE TO LOS ANGELES.
BECAUSE THEY ALWAYS SAY THAT
PEOPLE LOOK LIKE LITTLE ANTS
WHEN YOU'RE UP THERE,
AND THEY DO!
♪♪♪
IT'S EXCITING.
WE'RE ALL HAPPY TO BE HERE.
(laughing)
HOW MANY GIRLS
WERE AT, LIKE, THE TRYOUT?
I DON'T KNOW.
IT WAS LIKE 95% BLACK GIRLS.
IT WAS ALL BLACK GIRLS.
REALLY?
I DIDN'T REALIZE
IT WAS GONNA BE LIKE THAT.
LIKE, WHENEVER I WENT,
I WAS LIKE OKAY.
I MEAN, WHAT'S YOUR POINT,
THOUGH?
LIKE THERE'S JUST
A LOT OF BLACK GIRLS.
I HAVE MY OPINION,
AND I TRY TO STAY TO IT.
I AM THE MOST UBER-CONSERVATIVE,
REPUBLICAN, HARDCORE-BAPTIST
YOU COULD EVER IMAGINE
IN YOUR WHOLE LIFE.
I DON'T LIKE GAY PEOPLE.
I DON'T LIKE MUSLIMS.
I DON'T LIKE ABORTIONS.
I DON'T LIKE ANYTHING LIBERAL,
BUT OTHER THAN THAT,
I REALLY LIKE TO GET ALONG
WITH PEOPLE.
USUALLY IT'S LIKE HALF BLACK,
HALF WHITE OR, YOU KNOW,
MORE WHITE, JUST BECAUSE
BLACK PEOPLE ARE NATURALLY LIKE,
POPULATION WISE, LIKE MINORITY.
DANI WAS DIGGING HERSELF
A LITTLE DEEPER
INTO THE RACIAL POOL,
AND THEN I WAS LIKE, WELL,
"YOU ARE NOT GONNA MAKE ME
THE ANGRY BLACK WOMAN."
♪♪♪
OH, MY GOODNESS, LOOK.
HUH, OOH, OOH, OOH!
SHUT UP!
YES! YES!
NOW I'M GONNA SPEAK TO YOU.
♪♪♪
I'M NERVOUS.
I'M EXCITED.
I'M ANXIOUS.
IT'S LIKE I'M ONE BALL
OF EMOTION.
♪♪♪
EVERYONE'S LIKE SO DIFFERENT,
BUT WE'RE ALL GOING
AFTER THE SAME THING,
AND IT'S SHOCKING.
I'M STILL IN SHOCK
THAT I'M HERE.
♪♪♪
EVERYBODY THINKS
I'M VERY DOWN-TO-EARTH.
I HAVE THIS STYLE.
I'M VERY COOL, AND, YOU KNOW,
I'M VERY INTIMIDATING
TO A LOT OF THESE GIRLS.
(screams)
OH, MY GOD!
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
OF GIRLS ACROSS AMERICA--
YOU ARE THE LUCKY 32.
YEAH!
SO CLEARLY, YOU GUYS,
OBVIOUSLY, KNOW MISS J.
WHO'S STANDING HERE TO MY RIGHT.
(cheers)
AND MR. JAY ON MY LEFT.
TODAY, RIGHT OFF THE PLANE,
WE ARE GONNA GIVE YOU GIRLS
YOUR VERY FIRST CHALLENGE.
ARE YOU READY, MISS J.?
ARE YOU READY?
LET'S GO.
(screams)
WE ARE GONNA GIVE YOU GIRLS
THREE MINUTES
TO PUT TOGETHER AN OUTFIT
USING YOUR OWN CLOTHES
THAT BEST EVOKES
ONE OF THESE THREE WALKS
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
ON THIS SCREEN
RIGHT HERE TO MY LEFT
WITH OUR VERY OWN
MISS TYRA BANKS.
TYRA'S VERY FIRST CLIP HERE
IS SULTRY, SEXY,
DRIPPING FROM THE FINGERTIPS.
AND I MEAN OOZING
FROM THE FINGERTIPS.
AND HER SECOND LOOK HERE
IS MISS SOPHISTICATED LADY.
THAT'S RIGHT.
AND TYRA'S THIRD WALK RIGHT HERE
IS YOUNG, VIRGINAL AND UPBEAT.
YOU GUYS HAVE GOT TO START
PROVING TO US RIGHT NOW
THAT YOU CAN SERVE IT UP
AND BE A TOP MODEL.
ALL RIGHT, SO YOU READY?
ALL RIGHT, GO!
(screams)
♪♪♪
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA,
HEY, HEY, GIRL, I DON'T NEED TO
SEE YOUR BUTT HERE, GO INSIDE.
CHILD.
THAT'S RIGHT.
SORRY.
WHOOPS, I WAS LIKE,
WHY DIDN'T YOU TELL ME?
♪♪♪
I'M SO EXCITED.
WHO'S EXCITED?
(cheers)
THESE GIRLS BETTER WATCH OUT,
BECAUSE I HAVE THE AMBIANCE.
I HAVE THE DRESS GOIN',
THE HAIR.
HERE WE GO, BABY.
LET'S ROCK.
♪♪♪
OKAY,
I'M NOT MAD AT MISS JADE.
EVER SINCE I WAS LITTLE,
I WOULD ALWAYS WEAR
MY MOM'S HEELS, MAKEUP,
LIKE SMEARED ALL OVER MY FACE.
I REALLY WANT TO BE A MODEL.
♪♪♪
I HAD ON A LONG WIG,
BECAUSE MY HAIR IS SHORT.
TYRA, SHE HAD HAIR LIKE THAT
IN ONE OF HER VIDEOS.
GOT SOME HAIR LIKE THAT
IN MY BAG.
I CAN GO PULL IT OUT.
♪♪♪
OH!
OH, OH, RIGHT THERE.
I'M A DOCTOR,
AND PEOPLE ALWAYS LOOK AT ME,
THEY'RE LIKE, WHAT?
YOU'RE A DOCTOR?
YOU WANT TO BE A MODEL.
HER WALK IS FEARSOME.
OVER FOR THE WALK.
I LOVE THE DAISY DUKE.
THAT'S ACTUALLY CUTE.
I HAD, LIKE, A PANG OF FEAR
GO THROUGH ME,
BECAUSE I WAS TRYING
TO PICK UP MY FEET
AND NOT FALL
AND STRIKE A FIERCE POSE
WHEN I DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT A FIERCE POSE LOOKS LIKE.
♪♪♪
OH, I LIKE HER TOP.
I WONDER IF I COULD WEAR THAT.
♪♪♪
I FEEL LIKE
I AM STRUTTING THE STUFF,
AND I'M LOOKING THE J's
RIGHT IN THE EYE.
CAN'T YOU SEE
HOW MUCH I WANT THIS?
ALL RIGHT.
WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I GOT TO SAY,
YOU GUYS NEED A LOT OF WORK
TO GET TO THE FINAL 13.
THERE WERE A FEW OF YOU
THAT CAME CLOSE TO MISS BANKS.
CAME CLOSE, YES,
BUT ONE OF YOU DID STAND OUT.
YVONNE.
(cheers)
COME OVER HERE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF GIRLS HERE
THAT ARE GREAT,
BUT IT'S ABOUT WHAT YOU BRING
TO THE TABLE,
AND I'M GONNA BRING EVERYTHING
TO THE TABLE
AND BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
BRING IT ON, LADIES!
BYE!
I FELT LIKE A FAT KID
IN FOURTH GRADE
WHO GOT PICKED LAST
FOR THE DODGE BALL TEAM.
IT'S JUST LIKE
THIS IS THE BIGGEST COMPETITION
OF MY LIFE.
I THINK IT'S A TIME TO, LIKE,
STEP IT UP.
♪♪♪
(cheers)
SO I'M GLAD YOU GUYS
ARE HAVING A GREAT BREAKFAST.
AND, UM, BASICALLY,
WE'VE GOT SOME NOT-SO-GOOD NEWS.
TYRA CAN'T BE WITH US.
WE HAVE A TAPED MESSAGE
FOR YOU GUYS.
HEY, GIRLS,
I'M SO SORRY THAT I CAN'T
BE WITH YOU TODAY,
BUT I TRUST MR. AND MRS. J.,
SO I'M SORRY.
I DO TRUST MY BOYS,
AND YOU'RE HERE TO BE WHAT?
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL!
I CAN'T HEAR YOU!
ONE MORE TIME--WHAT?
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL!
(cheers)
WHAT?
(screams)
ALL OF A SUDDEN,
SHE COMES OUT OF THE DOOR
LIKE WOW!
I MEAN, I CAME--
I LIKE SHED A TEAR,
AND I'M NOT EVEN A CRYBABY.
I HAD TO BE HERE
TO SEE YOU GUYS!
I CHOSE ALL OF YOU GUYS.
I LOOKED AT EVERYBODY'S TAPE,
AND YOU KNOW,
SINCE "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
IS SO POPULAR NOW,
WE HAD TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF GIRLS,
WHICH Y'ALL STOOD OUT
BETTER THAN ALL OF 'EM!
(cheers)
TYRA, LIKE, SHE LOOKS LIKE
A LITTLE MANNEQUIN DOLL.
SHE'S SO, LIKE,
EVEN MORE GORGEOUS IN PERSON.
ANYBODY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
THEY WANT TO ASK ME?
I WANT YOU TO DO THE COW WALK
FOR US.
OH, YOU WA--OKAY.
OH, YEAH!
WHOO!
(cheers)
(screams)
BYE-BYE!
MY HEART JUST POUNDED
REAL FAST.
I'M LIKE,
THIS IS THE COMPETITION,
AND WE'RE IN COMPETITION NOW.
DON'T TALK TO ME.
♪♪♪
HI, GUYS.
HOW ARE YOU?
GREAT.
I'M GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
MY NAME'S SARA,
AND I'M ACTUALLY JUST GRADUATED
FROM GEORGETOWN UNIVERSITY.
SO, SARA,
YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO STAND
IN A LINE FOREVER
FOR THIS AUDITION.
WE FOUND YOU IN A MALL
AND CHASED YOU DOWN.
I WAS ACTUALLY SHOPPING
WITH MY FRIEND,
AND SOMEONE COMES UP TO ME,
AND SHE WAS LIKE, "WELL,
YOU SHOULD REALLY TRY OUT
FOR 'AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.'"
I'VE ALWAYS WONDERED
ABOUT MODELING.
I'VE BEEN APPROACHED
IN THE PAST,
BUT I'VE ALWAYS BEEN AN ATHLETE.
HOW DO YOU FEEL
ABOUT BEING 6'1"?
IT DID AFFECT ME A LOT
GROWING UP,
AND I WAS PRETTY INSECURE
ABOUT IT FOR A WHILE.
MY NICKNAME IS "GLAMAZON,"
AND THAT'S BECAUSE I AM SO TALL,
LIKE AN AMAZON WOMAN.
AND RELAX YOUR FACE.
SO I'VE ALWAYS WONDERED
WHAT MY POTENTIAL WOULD BE
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS COMPETITION
IS ABOUT FOR ME.
HOW MANY DESIGNERS
HIRE MODELS THAT ARE 6'1"?
OLUCHI IS 6'2".
SHE'S STILL
A VERY SUCCESSFUL MODEL,
BUT YOU ARE MAKING A GOOD POINT,
BECAUSE PEOPLE THINK THAT MODELS
ARE 6'1", 6'2".
THEY'RE NOT.
THEY'RE 5'9" TO 5'11".
♪♪♪
WORK IT.
(laughing)
I'M FURONDA.
I'M 24 YEARS OLD, AND I'M FROM
STUTTGART, ARKANSAS--
THE BOONDOCKS.
SO TELL ME
WHAT YOU USED TO DO
TO MAKE SOME MONEY.
IT INVOLVES A VERY SEXY VOICE.
GOD, YES, IT DOES.
I USED TO BE
A PHONE SEX OPERATOR.
THEY TELL YOU WHAT KIND OF GIRL
THEY WANTED TO SPEAK TO.
IT'S LIKE, BEEP,
BLACK AND BEAUTIFUL.
DO THAT ONE.
YEAH, MM-HMM.
I JUST CAME FROM OVER THERE,
AND ME AND MY HOME GIRLS
WAS CHILLIN' 'N' STUFF.
(imitates valley girl)
OH,MY GOD!
HEY, HOW ARE YOU?
(imitates dominatrix)
WHY ARE YOU CALLING?
WHAT DO YOU WANT?
(imitates big and beautiful)
HUH, HUH!
YEAH.
OH, LET ME MOVE OVER
TO MY OTHER COUCH,
SO I CAN HAVE SOME ROOM
TO SPREAD MY LEGS OUT.
I WOULD CONSIDER MYSELF
A CHAMELEON.
MY ABILITIES TO TRANSFORM
AND MORPH
INTO DIFFERENT CHARACTERS
IS GONNA HELP ME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SHE WALKED
LIKE HER FEET HURT.
YEAH, BUT YOU KNOW--
I SEE THE FACE UP CLOSE.
I SEE IT.
SHE LOOKS
LIKE A PRAYING MANTIS.
SO IN THE FASHION WORLD,
THAT COULD BE--
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
HI, GUYS.
HI, KARI.
SO WHY DO YOU WANT TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
FIRST OF ALL, I WANT
TO GET OUT OF SOUTH DAKOTA.
I'M ONLY 18,
SO I JUST FINISHED HIGH SCHOOL.
I KNOW THE MODEL INDUSTRY.
THEY TRY TO START
THE YOUNGEST YOU CAN.
OTHER THAN TYRA,
CAN YOU NAME FIVE TOP MODELS
THAT ARE OUT THERE IN THE MARKET
RIGHT NOW?
UM, GISELE,
UM, ADRI--ADRIANA LIMA.
(crickets chirping)
SOMEONE WHO DOES NOT
HAVE A VICTORIA'S SECRET
CONTRACT.
I--I WANT TO BE
A VICTORIA'S SECRET GIRL.
THIS IS SO REAL.
IT SINKS IN.
IT IS HAPPENING AT THIS MOMENT.
I THINK I'M MEANT TO BE HERE.
KARI LOOKS LIKE A BRAT DOLL.
SHE DOES, LIKE...
SHE DOES!
BRAT DOLLS ARE FIERCE,THOUGH.
WHAT'S UP, EVERYBODY?
AH!
WHY ARE YOU SO HAPPY?
I'M JUST EXCITED
TO SEE YOU GUYS.
SO YOU ARE
AN EMERGENCY ROOM DOCTOR.
YOU GUYS, I'M AT WORK.
I HAVE TO GO IN.
I WOULD LOVE TO INVITE ALL
OF AMERICA INTO THE HOSPITAL.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT'S GONNA
COME THROUGH THE DOORS.
FROM ANYWHERE FROM A LITTLE KID
WITH A LITTLE RUNNY NOSE
TO A FULL-BLOWN HEART ATTACK,
YOU KNOW,
YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHAT TO DO.
(choking)
HEY!
COME ON! QUICK!
SOMEONE GET UP!
THAT'S JUST MISS J.
HE'S ALWAYS TRIPPIN'.
(coughs)
ARE YOU OKAY?
(laughing)
I THINK
HE'S GONNA BE ALRIGHT, PEOPLE.
CIAO, GIRL, MISS YVONNE.
ALL RIGHTY.
WELL, CAN YOU GIVE US
A RUNWAY WALK?
WHEN SHE
DID THE RUNWAY CHALLENGE,
SHE WON THE RUNWAY CHALLENGE.
I LOVE MEDICINE, BUT MODELING
IS LIKE A PASSION FOR ME,
AND IT'S SOMETHING
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO DO,
SO THIS IS ANOTHER PART
OF YVONNE.
SHE HAS THE TYPE OF LOOK
THAT THE FASHION INDUSTRY LOVES
RIGHT NOW.
♪♪♪
MY NAME IS WENDY.
I'M 22 AND FROM
NEW ORLEANS, LOUISIANA.
NEW ORLEANS!
YES.
OKAY, I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT HURRICANE KATRINA,
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT YOU
WERE ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
THAT WE SAW ON TV
HAVING TO EVACUATE,
SO WHY DON'T YOU TELL ME
ABOUT THAT.
THIS IS LIKE
AN EMOTIONAL ROLLER COASTER.
LIKE, I DID GET TO EVACUATE,
BUT I NEVER JUST THOUGHT,
LIKE, IN A MILLION YEARS,
I WOULD LEAVE MY HOUSE
AND NOT BE ABLE TO GO BACK.
WENDY, DO YOU THINK
YOU CAN HANDLE THIS COMPETITION?
IT'S LIKE I'M SO EXCITED
THAT I'M HERE,
BUT IT'S LIKE HARD TRYING
TO JUST PUT ASIDE EVERYTHING.
THE LAST TIME
I DID TALK TO MY DAD,
HE WAS LIKE,
THEY WERE TRYING TO EVACUATE,
AND THEY JUST SLEPT IN A CAR
FOR, LIKE, TWO DAYS,
AND HE SAID THEY STOPPED
ON A BRIDGE
AND HE WOKE UP THE NEXT MORNING.
HE SAID THE WATER ROSE
ON BOTH SIDES,
AND HE COULDN'T GO ANYWHERE.
AND AFTER THAT--
THAT WAS THE LAST TIME
I TALKED TO HIM.
YOU DON'T KNOW
WHERE THEY ARE?
NO.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
GIVE ME A HUG.
I DIDN'T KNOW.
♪♪♪
YOU KNOW,
IT'S HARD STAYING FOCUSED,
BUT I'M NOT GIVING UP.
I'M GONNA DO WHAT I HAVE TO DO
TO GET THERE.
I JUST THINK THAT MY MOM
WOULD BE LIKE SO PROUD
THAT I'M HERE.
♪♪♪
IT'S LIKE
I WANNA CRY RIGHT NOW,
AND I FEEL LIKE I CAN'T.
YOU'RE DOING THE RIGHT THING.
I'M VERY CLOSE TO MY FAMILY.
I'VE NEVER BEEN AWAY FROM THEM
MORE THAN A DAY,
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I'M STRUGGLING WITH NOW.
YOU REALLY HUG ME REALLY HARD.
YES! YES!
YES, YES, YES.
♪♪♪
I'M SO EXCITED TO BE HERE.
I'VE BEEN WAITING FOR THIS DAY
FOREVER, FOREVER!
OKAY.
SO MY NAME IS JADE,
AND, UM, TYRA,
YOU'RE SUCH AN INSPIRATION
TO ME.
THE TWO J's, AMAZING.
I NEED A TEAM--
TYRA, THE TWO MISS J's,
ARE MY TEAM,
AND THEY'RE GONNA MAKE ME SHINE.
PEOPLE THINK I'M A BITCH
WHEN THEY FIRST MEET ME,
BECAUSE, OH, I'M PRETTY.
I HAVE THIS BEAUTIFUL BODY,
BUT WHEN THEY GET TO KNOW ME,
I'M SO COOL.
I'M VERY REAL.
EVERY TIME I WALK
DOWN THE STREET, I--
I MEAN, HEADS ARE LIKE TURNIN'.
LIKE LOOK AT THIS.
PEOPLE KNOW--
THEY KNOW JADE.
THEY KNOW MY FACE.
I'M READY TO WIN.
I'M READY TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
'CAUSE I KNOW I HAVE
WHAT IT TAKES.
AND I CANNOT WAIT TO BE ME
AND SHOW THE WORLD WHO I AM.
I'M GONNA BLOW THEM AWAY,
AND THEN THEY'RE GONNA SEE
WHO JADE REALLY IS.
HUMILITY, SHE DOES LACK!
SHE'S SO LIKE A NATURE GIRL,
AFRO, LIKE AFROCENTRIC BEADS.
YOU'D THINK SHE'D BE LIKE,
MY SISTER, WE ARE ALL BEAUTIFUL,
BUT SHE'S LIKE, SCREW THIS!
I'M FINE!
HEY, Y'ALL!
HI, GINA.
SO WHY DO YOU WANT TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
I THINK THAT
THERE'S JUST NOT ENOUGH
ASIAN MODELS OUT THERE.
I FEEL THAT
I CAN BREAK DOWN THAT BARRIER,
AND I THINK
IT'S MY RESPONSIBILITY.
YOU SAY THAT YOU'RE NOT
THE GIRL NEXT-DOOR.
YOU'RE WILD.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY THAT?
IF YOU WERE TO ASK ME
TO GET DOWN AND STRIP NAKED,
I WILL DO IT.
THAT'S JUST HOW I AM.
WELL?
BUT THE THING IS, LIKE,
MY PARENTS KIND OF HAVE
A THING WITH THAT, SO, I MEAN,
I DON'T KNOW IF I WOULD GO
AGAINST MY PARENTS OR NOT.
I'M NOT SURE.
I MEAN--
HEY, YOU...
I KIND OF BELIEVE MORE
IN THE AMERICAN CULTURE
MORE THAN MY PARENTS.
OH!
I'M NOT INTO ASIAN GUYS.
WHY NOT?
THE THING IS,
THEY'RE A LOT SHORTER THAN I AM,
WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT I CAN'T TOLERATE.
YOU'VE COME SO FULL CIRCLE
FROM YOUR INITIAL STATEMENT.
BUT DO YOU UNDERSTAND
HOW YOU WERE A CONTRADICTION?
FIRST YOU WERE SAYING--
I'M ASIAN, I'M STRONG,
I'M KOREAN--
AND THEN YOU'RE SAYING--
SCREW KOREAN BOYS,
AND I WANT A WHITE BOY.
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT EXACTLY HAPPENED,
BUT I GOT CONFUSED,
AND I STARTED
CONTRADICTING MYSELF,
BECAUSE CERTAIN THINGS
JUST STARTED COMING OUT,
AND IT DIDN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
♪♪♪
GOD.
OOH, I SUCKED SO BAD.
OH, GOD!
I USED TO THINK
THAT I WAS LIKE REALLY STRONG,
AND I COULDN'T EVEN WALK.
I WAS WOBBLING.
YEAH.
IF YOU SAW
WHAT HAPPENED IN THERE,
YOU'D JUST BE LIKE, OH!
MY NAME IS TANIKA.
EVERYONE CALLS ME T.K.
T.K., IT SAYS HERE
YOU HAD IT ROUGH GROWING UP.
TELL ME ABOUT THAT.
MY MOTHER IS WHITE,
AND, YES, WE LIVED
IN THE GHETTO.
I WAS THE ONLY MIXED GIRL
ON THE BLOCK, SO--
GIRLS WHO DIDN'T HAVE
SUCH GOOD HAIR--
(needle scratching record)
LOOKING AT ME
LIKE AN OUTCAST.
CAN YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN
TO THE THREE OF US
WHAT'S GOOD HAIR?
(laughs)
GOOD HURR!
GOOD HURR IS YOU DON'T HAVE
THE KITCHEN IN THE BACK,
AND YOU DON'T HAVE THE, YOU
KNOW, BUCKSHOTS COMING OUT.
I'M DEFINITELY MORE
THAN JUST A PRETTY FACE.
I'M LIKE ON THE FENCE WITH HER.
HI.
YOU'RE A GRAPE SQUASHER,
FARMER GIRL.
WELL, I GREW UP ON THE FARM
MAKING WINE WITH MY FAMILY.
MY MOM IS MY BEST FRIEND.
MY DAD IS MY HERO.
EVERY TIME I THINK OF THEM,
I CAN'T HELP BUT CRY,
'CAUSE I KNOW HOW MUCH
THEY SUPPORT ME IN THIS.
IF YOU WERE TO GET
INTO THIS COMPETITION,
YOU WOULD HAVE TO LEAVE HOME
AND LIVE IN A HOUSE
AND BE AWAY FROM THE FAMILY.
IT WOULD BE HARD,
I'M NOT GONNA LIE,
AND, UM, I WOULD CRY AND--
BECAUSE THAT'S ME.
I CRY.
IT'S A BIG DEAL,
AND I WANT IT SO BAD,
AND YOU DON'T GET CHANCES,
FROM WHERE I'M FROM, LIKE THIS,
AND, UM--
SHE NEEDS TO EAT SOMETHING,
TYRA, OTHER THAN GRAPES.
HI.
COME ON IN.
WORK IT.
I AM COMING, GIRL!
I AM COMING!
MY NAME IS LEAH, 19.
I'M FROM BOCA RATON, FLORIDA,
A.K.A. THE RAT'S MOUTH, OKAY.
SO WHY DO YOU WANT TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
BECAUSE I HAVE
ALL THIS PASSION.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND?
THERE'S THIS FIRE.
IT'S ALL BURNING.
YOU TOUCH IT, AND IT--
PSHEW--EXPLODES!
SO YOU'RE A GO-GO DANCER?
OH-KAY!
I'M AWESOME.
I'M LIKE THE BEST GO-GO DANCER
EVER TO BE CREATED.
OH! OH!
HO!
AH!
OH, YEAH, LET IT DROP!
♪♪♪
WORK IT.
OKAY.
THIS IS MY BEST GRAPE SQUASHIN'.
♪♪♪
MY NAME IS DRACULA.
HA!
♪♪♪
WHOA!
YOUR DADDY IS A PREACHER.
TELL US ABOUT GROWING UP
AS A PREACHER'S DAUGHTER.
I KNOW--
I RESPECT WHAT MY DAD DOES.
HE'S A GREAT GUY.
HE'S A LEADER.
HE'S A SHEPHERD
TO HUNDREDS OF SHEEP.
YOU'RE SO SHELTERED AS A CHILD,
AND THEN WHEN YOU GROW UP,
YOU REBEL,
AND YOU'RE JUST CRAZY AND--
SO WHAT DID YOU DO TO REBEL?
I KIND OF DID SOME
AMATEUR NIGHTS AT STRIP CLUBS--
(needle scratching record)
AND THEN I WAS A CAGE DANCER
FOR A WHILE.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE SPECIFIC
REBELLING AGAINST DADDY.
SHOW ME YOUR BEST PREACHER'S
DAUGHTER CAGE DANCE MOVES.
CLAP A LITTLE BIT.
♪♪♪
MY DAD DOES NOT KNOW
I'VE DONE AMATEUR NIGHTS
OR THAT I WAS A CAGE DANCER,
BUT THE LORD IS THE ONLY ONE
THAT CAN JUDGE ME.
HI, GUYS.
WHAT'S UP?
HI, LESLIE.
I'M 18.
I'M FROM HIGLEY, ARIZONA.
HIGLEY?
YEP, HIGLEY!
MY GRANDPARENTS
HAD A HUGE INFLUENCE
ON THE WAY THAT I WAS RAISED.
THEY'RE HISPANIC,
SO IF I BROUGHT HOME
A BLACK GUY, IT'D JUST BE LIKE--
ALL HELL WOULD BREAK LOOSE.
WHAT IF YOU BROUGHT HOME
MISS J.?
THEY DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
AGAINST BLACK WOMEN.
HERE'S THE THING--
(laughing)
WAIT! I LOVE THAT!
I LOVE THAT!
YOU KNOW WHAT, LESLIE?
YOU'RE NOW MY FRIEND FOR LIFE.
BLACK WOMEN!
YOU MADE HIS DAY.
LOVE THAT.
I COULD BRING
I LOT OF DIVERSITY,
AND I COULD BRING
A LOT OF VERSATILITY,
BECAUSE I CAN PASS FOR LATINO.
I CAN PASS FOR ASIAN.
I CAN PASS FOR BLACK.
CAN I SEE
WHAT'S BELOW THE BELT?
IT SAYS,
"WHAT NOURISHES ME DESTROYS ME,"
AND ANGELINA JOLIE HAS IT.
THANK YOU.
SHE HAS THAT S-CURVE WALK.
YES.
DIDN'T YASMEEN
HAVE THE SAME KIND OF THING,
SO ONE HIP LOOKED OFF
FROM THE RIGHT?
YES.
AND SHE BECAME A HUGE MODEL.
WHAT'S UP, EVERYBODY?
WHAT'S UP?
I AM STARVING.
THERE IS NO IF, ANDs
AND BUTs ABOUT IT,
THERE IS NO GOING HOME FOR ME.
I DID NOT COME ALL THE WAY
FROM LITTLE BITTY
LITTLE ROCK, ARKANSAS,
TO GET TURNED AROUND
AND GO HOME.
THAT'S NOT AN OPTION.
I'M HELLA FOCUS RIGHT NOW,
'CAUSE I WANT THAT TITLE.
I AM GONNA GET THAT TITLE.
(thud)
OOH! OOH! AH!
I MEANT TO DO THAT!
(laughing)
WHEN I WAS 12 YEARS OLD
WHEN I WENT TO MY FAMILY,
AND I WAS LIKE,
"I WANNA BE A SUPERMODEL."
AND I WALKED FOR THEM.
THEY'VE BEEN CALLING ME
THEIR LITTLE MODEL EVER SINCE.
I WANNA TALK ABOUT YOUR MOM,
'CAUSE YOU'RE HELPING HER OUT
BECAUSE OF HER AILMENT
AND STUFF,
SO WHY DON'T YOU TELL US
ABOUT THAT?
WELL, MY MOM IS LIKE MY ROCK.
SHE IS MY BEST FRIEND,
BUT SHE HAS RHEUMATOID ARTHRITIS
AND HER JOINTS ARE DEFORMED.
LIKE, HER HANDS
ARE REALLY SWOLLEN.
HAVING TO SHOWER MY MOTHER,
AND SHE WOULD ALWAYS SAY LIKE
I'M SORRY, I'M SORRY,
AND I'M LIKE,
YOU DON'T HAVE TO APOLOGIZE,
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE MY MOM.
I'M GONNA TAKE CARE OF YOU.
BUT IT'S LIKE
IT'S MADE ME STRONGER,
AND I KNOW IN THIS INDUSTRY,
YOU GOTTA HAVE TOUGH SKIN.
I GOT GATOR SKIN
WITHOUT THE BUMPS,
SERIOUSLY, SO...
THAT'S WHERE I GET
MY STRENGTH FROM AND MY DRIVE,
BECAUSE I SEE MY MOTHER DOING IT
AND SHE'S SUPER WOMAN TO ME,
SO SHE'S MY EVERYTHING.
♪♪♪
WE GO OUT TO HAVE DINNER
AND GET TO MEET THE GIRLS MORE
AND GET TO KNOW EACH OTHER
A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
WOW, THIS IS SO GOOD!
I'M REALLY HAPPY.
I'M USED TO MY LITTLE
SPRING, TEXAS.
EVERYTHING IN MY LIFE'S PERFECT,
AND THEN I COME HERE.
SO WHAT TYPE OF RACISM
DO YOU HAVE FOR PEOPLE
TO THINK THAT YOU'RE RACIST?
FOR ONE THING, I DON'T
BELIEVE IN AFFIRMATIVE ACTIONS,
LIKE...
BIGGEST LOAD OF CRAP
I'VE EVER HEARD
IN MY WHOLE LIFE, EVER.
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
MM-HMM
THE COLOR OF YOUR SKIN
MEANS ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
BECAUSE WHAT?
WHY WOULD BLACK PEOPLE GO--
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WHY WOULD--CALM DOWN.
I'M NOT SAYING ANYTHING MEAN.
YOU HAVEN'T LET ME FINISH.
YOU DON'T THINK
BEFORE YOU SPEAK
AND THE WORDS COME OUT WRONG.
NO--YOU NEED TO WATCH
WHAT YOU SAY BEFORE YOU SAY IT.
DANI ENDS UP ALWAYS
COMING ACROSS RACIST,
WHICH SHE SAYS SHE'S NOT,
BUT EVERYONE SWEARS SHE--
JUST BECAUSE SHE ALWAYS
IS SAYING RACIST REMARKS.
I'M NOT THE KIND OF PERSON
THAT'S GONNA SUGAR COAT THINGS.
I'M NOT GONNA TELL 'EM
AND BE LIKE,
"I'M SORRY I FEEL THAT WAY.
I'M SORRY IT OFFENDS YOU."
'CAUSE I'M NOT SORRY.
WHY WOULD I GO APPLY FOR A JOB
AT LIKE SOME FUBU RETAIL
WHATEVER?
WHY WOULD I DO THAT?
DANI RUBBED ME THE WRONG WAY.
SHE POPS OFF AT THE MOUTH
NOT THINKING
ABOUT WHAT SHE'S SAYING,
AND THAT GETS HER INTO TROUBLE,
AND IT'S GONNA CONTINUE
TO GET HER INTO TROUBLE.
YOU WANT ME TO OFFEND YOU.
NO, THAT'S WHAT YOU JUST--
HEY, BUT THE THING IS
IS THE WHOLE TABLE HEARD IT.
SHE'S NOT THE ONLY ONE
THAT FEELS THAT.
EVERYONE FEELS EXACTLY
HOW SHE FEELS.EVERYONE HEARD IT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
I KNOW HOW I FEEL AND YOU DON'T,
SO YOU CAN'T TELL ME
THAT I'M RACIST
WHEN I KNOW I'M NOT.
I REALLY HONESTLY DID NOT
KNOW THAT THERE WAS ANYONE
IN THE COMPETITION
THAT HAD VIEWS LIKE THAT.
THIS IS GONNA BE A LONG ROW
IF SHE'S IN THIS HOUSE WITH ME.
♪♪♪
BEING FROM A SMALL TOWN,
I REALLY WANTED TO GET OUT THERE
AND TRY TO EXPERIENCE
SOME NEW THINGS,
BECAUSE I HAVE NEVER
BEEN DANCING BEFORE.
HEY, ALL YOU GUYS,
DROPPING IT LIKE IT'S HOT.
♪♪♪
COME ON IN.
NO!
YES!
MY GOODNESS!
GUYS,
WE HAVE A HAPPY HILLBILLY.
YOU CALL YOURSELF
A HILLBILLY, DON'T YOU?
AND THIS IS MY HOUSE--
TRASHY AND HUMBLE
AS IT MAY SEEM.
I MIGHT NOT BE THE TALLEST
OR THE MOST TAN OR THE ONE
WITH THE BIGGEST BOOBS
OR THE ONE
WITH THE CLEAREST SKIN,
BUT, YOU KNOW, I FEEL IT.
YOU KNOW, I'M LIKE--
I'M IN THERE WITH 'EM.
ALL RIGHTY.
GO PUT ON THAT SWIMSUIT.
I'M FROM THE MOUNTAINS,
BUT IT'S NOT
"THE BEVERLY HILLBILLIES."
ALTHOUGH,
I AM GOING TO LOS ANGELES,
AND I'M GONNA GET TO SWIM
IN A CEMENT POND.
IT'S NOT--
IT'S NOT TYPICAL PRETTY.
IT'S THAT MODEL PRETTY
WHERE IT'S A LITTLE OFF.
HI.
HI. MY NAME IS NNENNA.
I'M 24 YEARS OLD,
AND I'M FROM HOUSTON, TEXAS,
WHERE I CURRENTLY WORK
AS A CHEMIST
WITH AN OIL COMPANY.
RIGHT,
BUT YOU HAVE AN ACCENT,
SO WHERE ARE YOU
ORIGINALLY FROM?
WHEN I WAS 2-YEARS-OLD,
MY PARENTS AND I MOVED
BACK TO NIGERIA.
SO YOU'RE AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN.
YES, I AM.
WITH A NIGERIAN FLAVOR.
WE ENDED UP
SPENDING 12 YEARS IN NIGERIA.
I HAVE FOUR SISTERS.
MY DAD'S FAMILY
DIDN'T LIKE MY MOM,
BECAUSE SHE WASN'T ABLE
TO HAVE A BOY.
WHEN SHE HAD HER FOURTH GIRL,
THE DOCTOR TOLD HER SHE
SHOULDN'T HAVE ANY MORE KIDS.
BUT MY DAD,
HE PUT PRESSURE ON MY MOM.
SHE ENDED UP GETTING PREGNANT
A FIFTH TIME,
AND TEN DAYS AFTER SHE HAD
MY YOUNGEST SISTER, SHE DIED.
AND MY DAD WASN'T ABLE
TO TAKE CARE OF ALL FIVE OF US,
SO HE PUT MY SISTER AND I
ON THE PLANE TO COME BACK
HERE TO AMERICA.
AND MY AUNT WAS OUR
LEGAL GUARDIAN IN AUSTIN.
SO COMING TO AMERICA
GAVE ME HOPE.
I ALWAYS WANTED TO COME HERE
AND BE A MODEL.
YOU REMIND ME OF IMAN.
I THINK YOU HAVE SUCH
STRONG PRIDE.
YOU STAND LIKE A STRONG
AFRICAN WOMAN.
THANK YOU.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MY DAD WOULD
TAKE THIS MODELING THING.
WHEN HE PUT US ON THE PLANE
TO COME BACK TO AMERICA,
HE'S LIKE, "YOU GO.
YOU'RE GONNA BE A DOCTOR."
THAT IS NOT WHAT I WANNA DO.
THIS IS MY CHANCE.
THIS IS MY ONLY CHANCE
TO GET WHAT I WANT.
HER BODY IS SICK.
HER BODY, LOVELY BODY.
YOU CAN SEE HER HOLDING
BACK A LOT.
I WANTED TO CRY.
HI.
MOLLIE SUE,
25, FROM TAMPA.
I'M NERVOUS,
AND DON'T MAKE ME CRY.
IT'S OKAY.
WE DON'T REALLY BITE.
JUST MISS J. DOES
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE.
TELL ME ABOUT THE BOYFRIEND
THAT YOU HAD TO GET RID OF.
THERE WAS A LONG PERIOD
OF MY LIFE OF JUST BACK
AND FORTH WITH THE SAME PERSON.
I JUST KIND OF LET HIM CONTROL
MY LIFE FOR NINE YEARS TOO LONG.
SO YOU SAID THAT
HE DIDN'T WANT YOU TO MODEL?
HE SAID IT WAS SHALLOW.
BEING WITH MY EX-BOYFRIEND,
I JUST NEVER FELT STRONG ENOUGH
TO DO SOMETHING ON MY OWN.
BUT NOW, I FINALLY JUST
HAD NOTHING HOLDING ME BACK.
YOU'RE JUST SO GLITTERY.
MY NAME IS SHKITA.
I'M 24,
AND I'M FROM WATTS, CALIFORNIA.
WATTS. HOLLA.
YEAH, WATTS, WITH TYRESE.
ALL RIGHTY, SO...
I SEE MY BOYFRIEND.
WHO?
YOU.
OH, LORD, I WAS ABOUT TO--
WELL GO GIVE HIM A HUG.
GO GIVE YOUR GIRLFRIEND A HUG.
WANT A HUG?
COME GIVE ME A HUG.
COME ON!
YOU HAVE A CRUSH ON HIM?
AIR KISSES.
THERE WE GO.
OKAY, SO YOU SAY AMERICA
WILL LABEL YOU
AS A GHETTO, BLACK BARBIE.
WHY?
BECAUSE I'M TALL AND DARK.
WELL, NOW I WANNA BE
BLACK BARBIE.
TYRA HAS A BEAUTIFUL BODY.
I WISH I WAS LIKE
REALLY IN HER SHOES, LIKE,
BUT I CAN GO GET A WONDERBRA.
I BET YOU
I'D LOOK AS GOOD AS HER.
♪♪♪
HI.
I'M MORE OF A HIPPIE.
I DON'T WEAR MAKEUP.
I DON'T BRUSH MY HAIR.
I'M BAREFOOT ALL THE TIME.
SO TELL ME WHY YOU LOVE
AIRPLANE FOOD SO MUCH.
IT TASTES
REALLY, REALLY GOOD.
I LIKE IT, TOO.
DO YOU?
OH, MY GOSH, WHEN YOU HEAR
THE CART COMING, IT'S LIKE,
IT'S COMING, IT'S COMING.
MISS THING HERE, HONEY,
SHE'S LIKE THIS...
(snores)
THAT CART COME?
LOOK.
JAY, THE FOOD'S COMIN'!
I FEEL THAT I STAND OUT
BECAUSE I DON'T LOOK QUITE LIKE
ANY OF THE OTHER GIRLS.
I'M NOT THE TYPICAL BLOND.
I'M NOT OVER THE TOP, WHOO!
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT
HER FACE, STANDING IN FRONT US,
THAT I WAS LIKE, WOW!
HELLO.
HI.
I'M DANI.
I'M 18 YEARS OLD,
AND I'M FROM SPRING, TEXAS.
SPRING, TEXAS.
YES, MA'AM.
WELL, MISS DANI,
I HEAR YOU'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN SOME VERY HEATED DEBATES.
LIKE EVER SINCE
I'VE BEEN HERE,
I'VE JUST BEEN ATTACKED
BY A LOT OF GIRLS,
BECAUSE WHAT I SAID
IN MY AUDITION IN HOUSTON
WAS TO GET PEOPLE'S ATTENTION.
I AM THE MOST UBER-CONSERVATIVE
REPUBLICAN YOU CAN EVER IMAGINE
IN YOUR WHOLE LIFE.
I DON'T LIKE GAY PEOPLE.
YOU'RE WALKING
INTO A BUSINESS
WHERE YOUR HAIRDRESSER,
YOUR MAKEUP ARTIST, EVERYONE--
THE PHOTOGRAPHER
AND THE DESIGNER ARE GAY.
THEY ACT LIKE I'VE NEVER
BEEN AROUND GAY PEOPLE.
I'M A CHEERLEADER.
I MEAN, I KNOW ABOUT GAY PEOPLE.
I JUST HAVE A MORAL OBLIGATION
TO MY CHURCH
AND I JUST DON'T AGREE
WITH YOUR LIFESTYLE.
I AM A HARD-ASS,
AND I KNOW THAT.
I DON'T APOLOGIZE
FOR MY OPINIONS.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU COULD
POSSIBLY BE GETTING INTO,
BECAUSE THE FASHION INDUSTRY
STANDS FOR EVERY SINGLE THING
THAT YOU ARE AGAINST.
FEELS LIKE THEY SHOULD HAVE
A MORE OPEN MIND
AS TO WHAT I WAS BORN IN.
WHAT I WAS RAISED IN.
YOU CAN'T CHOOSE
WHERE YOU COME FROM.
HMM... INTERESTING.
I JUST WISH THE PERSONALITY
MATCHED THE BODY, IN THIS CASE.
I THINK WE HAVE SOMETHING
THERE THAT WE COULD WORK WITH
AND KIND OF BREAK IT DOWN
AND REBUILD IT BACK UP.
SO I AM SURE YOU GIRLS
ARE ALL REALLY, REALLY ANXIOUS.
I SEE SOME OF THEM SHAKING
AND DOING THIS LITTLE THING
RIGHT HERE.
TONIGHT, WE HAVE TO NARROW
YOU GIRLS DOWN TO A GROUP OF 20.
OH, WOW.
OH!
LIKE, I'M REALLY NERVOUS
ABOUT IT.
BUT, IF I DON'T MAKE IT,
I WILL NOT CRY.
BUT I'M ALMOST POSITIVE
THAT I'M GONNA MAKE THE CUT.
HAVING SAID THAT,
THERE'S GREAT POTENTIAL
IN EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU.
EVERYBODY IS DIFFERENT.
THEY ALL LOOK GOOD AND IT'S
LIKE, SO HOW DO THEY GO ABOUT
PICKING WHO'S GOING HOME?
AT THE END OF THIS HALL,
THERE IS A ROOM
WITH 20 MAKEUP STATIONS IN IT.
IN EACH MAKEUP KIT,
THERE IS A PHOTO OF A GIRL.
THOSE 20 PHOTOS
REPRESENT THE YOUNG LADIES
GOING ON TO THE NEXT LEVEL
OF COMPETITION.
OH, MY GOD, THIS IS IT.
ARE YOU READY?
YEAH!
GO!
HOLD ME!
AT THE END OF THIS HALL,
THERE IS A ROOM
WITH 20 MAKEUP STATIONS IN IT.
ONE MAKEUP KIT FOR EACH OF
OUR 20 FINALISTS.
I GUESS WE'RE READY.
GO!
HOLD ME!
WHERE'S THE PICTURE AT?
(screams)
I WAS LIKE,
THERE'S NO OTHER ASIAN GIRL.
THAT'S ME! THAT'S ME!
MOLLIE.
(screams)
JUST SURPRISED.
LIKE, I WASN'T EVEN EXPECTING IT
AT ALL AFTER THE PANEL.
JUST TO SEE MY PICTURE--
ALL THE EMOTIONS.
THE GIRLS BETTER WATCH OUT,
'CAUSE I'M GETTIN' IN THE HOUSE.
I'M SO HAPPY RIGHT NOW.
(screams)
OH, MY GOD! OH, MY GOD!
I THINK MY BOOBS
EVEN FELL OUT.
(screams)
IT'S JUST SO SURPRISING.
I ALMOST DIDN'T EVEN MAKE IT
TO THE AUDITION, BECAUSE
I ALMOST MISSED MY PLANE.
AND I ALMOST HAD TO MISS IT.
I JUST DIDN'T EXPECT TO
EVEN GET THIS FAR.
I FEEL SAD THAT SOME
OF THE GIRLS DIDN'T MAKE IT,
BUT THEN AGAIN, I DON'T
REALLY CARE AT THIS POINT,
CAUSE I'M HERE, SO WHATEVER.
♪♪♪
JUST BECAUSE I'M NOT GETTIN'
PICKED, I'M NOT GONNA STOP.
I'M GONNA KEEP GOING.
I'M GONNA JUST GO BACK TO MY JOB
WORKIN' AS A CASHIER,
BUT I'M GONNA STILL TRY
TO BE A MODEL.
(cheers)
WELL, TONIGHT IS WHERE
THE REAL COMPETITION STARTS,
AND YOU GIRLS ARE GONNA HAVE
YOUR VERY FIRST PHOTO SHOOT
TONIGHT.
(screams)
AND YOU HAVE TEN MINUTES
TO TAKE THE MAKEUP
IN THESE SILVER BOXES
AND DO YOUR MAKEUP.
IT IS A BEAUTY SHOT,
AND IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO REALIZE THAT THIS IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE TRICKIER SHOTS TO DO
BECAUSE IT'S JUST LETTING
YOUR FEATURES STAND OUT
FROM A VERY SIMPLE BACKGROUND
AND LIGHTING.
REMEMBER, MISS J., MYSELF
AND TYRA ARE GONNA BE LOOKING
AT THESE PHOTOS.
GOD KNOWS HOW BADLY
I WANT THIS AND HOW MUCH, LIKE,
I NEED THIS IN MY LIFE.
SO YOU HAVE TO WORK IT,
BECAUSE THERE'S STILL ONE MORE
CUT TO COME.
ALRIGHT? TEN MINUTES TO PUT
YOUR FACE ON, YOU GUYS COOL?
YEAH.
GO!
GOOD LUCK.
I NEED TO HAVE MY MIND
FOCUSED ON MY PHOTO SHOOT.
I MEAN, YOU'RE GONNA LOVE ME.
I'M--I'M FIERCE,
AND HERE I AM.
WELCOME, GIRLS.
WE'RE GONNA DO A REALLY QUICK,
DOWN-AND-DIRTY,
HEAD-AND-SHOULDERS BEAUTY SHOT.
I AM NOT GONNA POSE YOU.
YOU'RE ON YOUR OWN,
AND YOU'RE ONLY GONNA GET
TEN FRAMES, OKAY?
WHEN I MOVED TO NEW YORK,
I THOUGHT THAT, YOU KNOW,
IT WOULD BE EASY FOR ME
TO GET IN THE BUSINESS
AND TO BLOW UP AND MAKE IT,
BUT THAT WAS NOT THE CASE.
BEING THAT I AM 26 YEARS OLD,
I JUST WANT TO BE DISCOVERED.
I CAN GO TO THE SIDE,TOO,RIGHT?
YOU CAN DO WHATEVER
YOU'D LIKE.
AND THE SIDE PROFILE'S
A GOOD ONE FOR ME.
READY?
HERE WE GO.
TEN SHOTS,
SO KEEP MIXIN' IT UP.
I'M REALLY EXCITED
TO PROVE THAT I DESERVE
TO BE IN THIS COMPETITION.
AND YOU CAN USE YOUR ARMS?
SURE.
KATHY, I DON'T THINK
SHE HAS THAT MODEL LOOK TO HER.
I COULDN'T SEE HER IN THE HOUSE.
♪♪♪
MY GOAL IS TO WIN, AND SO
I JUST ZONE EVERYTHING OUT
AND DO WHAT I HAVE TO DO.
♪♪♪
WHEN I LOOK AT DANI,
I THINK SHE'S PRETTY,
BUT SHE DOESN'T STRIKE ME
AS A MODEL, SHE REALLY DOESN'T.
I DON'T EXPECT TO SEE HER
IN THE HOUSE.
THANK YOU, EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU, YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
IT'S DOWN TO THE WIRE,RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE AN ELIMINATION
TONIGHT.
WHOO!
SO SOME PEOPLE ARE GOIN' HOME.
♪♪♪
HOPIN' TO GO.
YEAH, YOU LOOK SO WORRIED!
IT'S HARD FOR ME,
BECAUSE NOT KNOWING WHAT--
WHAT'S GONNA BE HAPPENING.
NOTHING WE CAN DO ABOUT IT NOW.
I'VE NEVER BEEN AWAY
FROM MY HOME.
I KNOW THAT I NEED TO GROW UP,
BUT IT'S--IT'S OVERWHELMING.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS,
SO WE HAVE 20 GIRLS,
AND I THINK THE GIRLS
ARE REALLY, REALLY STRONG,
BUT WE HAVE TO NARROW IT DOWN
TO 13.
SO, MISS J., CALL UP THE FIRST
ANDREA.
SHE LOOKS GORGEOUS IN CLOTHES!
SHE IS A TRUE CLOTHES HANGER.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT GIRLS
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY
THAT HAVE EATING DISORDERS,
DO YOU THINK THAT THEIR BODIES
LOOK LIKE ANDREA?
I'M LOOKING RIGHT
AT THAT ARM NOW
AND JUST LOOKING AT THIS
LITTLE BIT RIGHT HERE.
SARA.
I ADORE SARA.
LET'S SEE SARA'S
CONTACT SHEET.
YOU SEE?
SHE HAS A LOT OF GOODS,
BUT SHE DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO WITH IT.
I JUST THINK SHE NEEDS
A FASHION INJECTION,
AND SHE'LL BE FINE.
NNENNA.
I LOVE THIS GIRL'S FACE.
I FEEL LIKE THE FASHION
INDUSTRY IS IN LOVE WITH
AND OBSESSED WITH GIRLS
FROM AFRICA.
THIS IS EDDIE MURPHY
AND IMAN'S BABY.
IT IS "COMING TO AMERICA."
EXACTLY.
JOANIE.
THIS GIRL SHOCKED ME.
IN FRONT OF ME, I WAS JUST LIKE,
NO, SEND HER HOME.
I DON'T EVEN THINK SHE SHOULD
BE IN THE 20 FINALISTS.
THEN I SEE THIS PHOTO,
AND I'M LIKE, THAT'S A MODEL!
SHE'S WORKING IT.
LOOK AT THAT PICTURE
AND LOOK AT THAT PICTURE!
I KNOW.
DANIELLE.
I THINK SHE'S SO FIERCE.
THAT'S ALMOST A LITTLE--
BEVERLY JOHNSON.
WE SHAVE THAT MUSTACHE,
BRING A LITTLE J.'s BASE
I JUST WANNA SHAVE
HER TOP LIP.
I JUST WANNA...
BRING UP THE NEXT GIRL.
MOLLIE--FIERCE.
WHAT ABOUT HER PERSONALITY?
SHE SEEMS ROBOTIC.
I'M MOLLIE.
I'M 25, FROM TAMPA.
I THINK SHE CAN BE TRAINED
WHEN YOU BRING IN
AN ACTING COACH.
KARI--I JUST FEEL LIKE
THERE'S A LITTLE SOMETHING THERE
THAT I DIDN'T SEE BEFORE.
OOH, I SO LIKE HER.
I THINK SHE'S ADORABLE.
I THINK SHE CAN BE
A COMMERCIAL MODEL, FOR SURE.
TANIKA.
I ACTUALLY KIND OF LIKE
I THINK SHE JUST NEEDS
A MAKEOVER.
SHE'S GOT THE WRONG
MAKEUP TECHNIQUE GOING ON.
AND I THINK IF WE JUST
GET HER IN THE MAKEOVER DAY,
MAYBE WE CAN MAKE A MIRACLE.
DANI.
DANI, DANI, DANI.
SHE SHOULD HAVE A DIPLOMA
RIGHT HERE.
IT'S A GRADUATION PHOTO.
WE SEE DANI'S CONTACT SHEET.
I THINK SHE HAS A REALLY
CUTE, EFFERVESCENT SMILE.
SHE COULD BE VERY COMMERCIAL.
DANI LOOKS LIKE SHE BELONGS
IN THE PTA,
AND SHE'S GONNA BE A NICE MOM.
BROOKE.
I LOVE THAT FACE.
I LOVE HER FACE, TOO.
IT'S A FACE THAT IS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THE PUBLIC
TO UNDERSTAND.
BUT THE FASHION WORLD--
WOULD LOVE HER.
LOVE IT. LOVE IT.
BECAUSE SHE LOOKS
LIKE THIS...
MM-HMM.
LESLIE.
LIKE JUST RIGHT OFF THE BAT,
I LIKE HER.
SHE NEEDS A LITTLE WORK.
SHE WAS THE DUCK BOOTY.
THIS IS THE GIRL
WITH THE DUCK BOOTY WALK,
THAT COME FOLLOW ME, BOYS.
EXACTLY.
JADE.
I'M SO GORGEOUS.
I'M SO PERFECT.
BUT IF THEY CAN TURN IT OUT.
AND LOOK AT THAT PICTURE.
SHE'S GOT SOME
BEAUTIFUL PICTURES.
SHE JUST NEEDS
A LITTLE GUIDANCE.
REBECCA.
SHE'S GOT GORGEOUS EYES.
I THINK SHE'S A PRETTY GIRL
AND TAKES A PRETTY PICTURE.
IS SHE A MODEL?
I DON'T KNOW.
FURONDA.
I JUST LIKE SAYING THAT.
I THINK SHE CAN DELIVER
SOMETHING THERE.
THE CAMERA LOVES HER FACE.
I DO THINK THIS GIRL COULD BE
WALKING MAJOR RUNWAY SHOWS.
GINA.
I LOVE GINA'S EYES
AND HER BONE STRUCTURE.
I DON'T THINK
SHE'S ODD ENOUGH.
I THINK SHE'S PLAIN.
BUT I FEEL LIKE
WITH THE RIGHT HAIR
AND THE RIGHT MAKEUP
AND EDGED OUT,
I THINK SHE COULD LOOK
ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
YVONNE.
OH, I, UM--I, UM...
OH, HEY, SHE NEEDS MAKEUP.
I LOVE YVONNE IN PERSON,
BUT, MY GOODNESS,
SHE DOES NOT HAVE A YOUNG FACE.
I LIKED HER SO MUCH
ON THE RUNWAY SHOW.
I LIKED HER SO MUCH IN PERSON.
SHE NEEDS TO LEARN HOW TO DO
SOME REALLY, REALLY AWKWARD,
LIKE UGH!
WENDY.
I THINK SHE HAS LOVELY EYES.
IF YOU LOOK AT HER FACE,
SHE'S GOT NO BOTTOM LASHES
AT ALL.
I THINK SHE'S ADORABLE.
I LOVE HER.
KATHERINE.
KATHERINE'S FACE
IS QUITE INTERESTING.
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS GIRL
I LIKE.
I LIKE HER, TOO.
SHE'S VERY EUROPEAN-LOOKING.
SOMETHING ABOUT HER I LIKE.
AND SHE JUST CALLS HERSELF
A HILLBILLY.
ALL RIGHTY, SO WE DID IT, AGAIN.
♪♪♪
NERVOUS, HUH?
(nervous laughter)
I'M NERVOUS, TOO.
THIS IS THE SIXTH TIME
THAT I HAVE DONE THIS,
AND I AM STILL VERY NERVOUS.
THERE ARE 20 OF YOU
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT, UNFORTUNATELY, ALL OF YOU
CAN'T BE IN THE RUNNING
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONLY 13 OF YOU
WILL BE IN THE RUNNING.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL--
(silence)
JADE.
(applause)
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
SARA.
(gasps)
THE NEXT NAME...
MOLLIE SUE.
MOLLIE, IF YOU LET A MAN
RUIN YOUR CHANCES
IN THIS COMPETITION,
I WILL HUNT HIM DOWN
AND THEN BEAT YOUR BUTT.
THE NEXT NAME IS SOMEONE
WHO SAYS, "WHAT NOURISHES HER
DESTROYS HER."
OH, MY GOD!
LESLIE.
OH, MY GOD.
THE NEXT NAME...
JOANIE.
JOANIE, WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE PREACHER MAN IS GONNA SAY?
UM, AMEN?
NNENNA.
YOU'RE SISTERS IN NIGERIA
HAVE A LOT TO BE PROUD OF
RIGHT NOW, DON'T THEY?
KARI.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
BIG-LIP BROOKE.
THE NEXT NAME--DANIELLE.
YEAH!
WHOA!
THANK YOU SO MUCH!
(imitates southern accent)
KATHERINE!
AH!
KATHERINE, GET YOUR BUTT
OVER HERE NOW, GIRL!
AH!
ALL RIGHT.
I HAVE THREE NAMES LEFT.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
FURONDA.
AH!
TWO NAMES LEFT.
GINA!
OH, MY GOD!
I LOVE ASIAN MEN!
I SWEAR TO GOD, I DO!
I DO NOW!
I DO!
MY GOD, I'M GONNA HUG YOU!
OH, MY GOD!
THE LAST NAME THAT I'M GOING
TO CALL WILL ROUND OUT
THESE 12 GIRLS HERE
AND MAKE IT 13,
AND OUT OF THAT 13,
ONE OF THOSE GIRLS IS GOING
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE LAST NAME...
WENDY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ONE THING THAT I WANT TO TELL
YOU--YOU'RE STANDING OVER THERE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE
A REALLY GREAT PERSONALITY
AND A LOT OF MODELING POTENTIAL.
IT'S NO PITY PARTY HERE.
THANK YOU.
WELL, Y'ALL CAN CELEBRATE.
(all yelling)
IT FEELS LIKE
I ENTERED A DREAM.
I'M GONNA, YOU KNOW,
REESTABLISH MY LIFE,
AND I'M GONNA START OVER NEW.
WHEN YOU GO TO BED TONIGHT,
YOU'RE PROBABLY GONNA CRY
AND FEEL SAD,
BUT JUST KNOW HOW FAR YOU GOT.
AND KNOW THAT I BELIEVE IN YOU
BECAUSE YOU WOULDN'T HAVE GOTTEN
THIS FAR.
I WASN'T PICKED.
I, UM, WAS HAVING TROUBLE
THE WHOLE WEEK
'CAUSE I AM SO CLOSE
TO MY FAMILY
AND MY HOME.
I HAVE CONSTANTLY BEEN TOLD
NO I CAN'T,
TO THIS DAY,
WITH THE THINGS I DO,
PEOPLE SAY IT'S NOT POSSIBLE.
I'M NOT--
I TOLD MYSELF I WOULDN'T CRY.
AND I JUST--I DIDN'T EXPECT IT
TO HIT ME THIS HARD.
AND EVERY DAY I GET UP
AND I SAY YES, IT IS POSSIBLE.
I'M SAD I DON'T GET TO GO
SEE THE WORLD AND COMPETE.
BUT ALSO, I GET TO GO HOME
AND GET TO GO BACK TO MY LIFE
AND MY FAMILY
AND CHEERLEADING.
THAT'S ALL THAT MATTERS.
WE MADE IT!
I KNOW.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT.
(screams)
GO, FURONDA!
I'M GONNA BE IN THE HOUSE OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
AND I'M COMING--
I'M BRINGING IT!
I'M COMING TO COMPETE!
JOANIE!
JO--JOANIE, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
MY DAD--I THINK
HE'S GONNA BE PROUD OF ME,
YOU KNOW?
IF I GOT THIS FAR, LIKE,
YOU KNOW, I'M UNSTOPPABLE.
GO, TYRA!
A'IGHT!
WHOO!
THE GIRLS ARE UP AGAINST
A HARD CHALLENGE,
BECAUSE I'M HERE TO WIN.
SO JUST WATCH OUT FOR JADE,
BECAUSE I'M GONNA BRING
THE FIRE, BABY.
(screams)
DON'T GO AWAY, THE SECOND PART
OF OUR TWO HOUR PREMIERE
IS NEXT.
THE GIRLS MOVE INTO
THEIR NEW DIGS.
(screaming)
AND THE GIRLS ARE THROWN INTO
THE MEDIA SPOT LIGHT,
WITH A LITTLE HELP FROM JANICE.
THEN, A MAKEOVER SHOCKER.
YOU GIRLS ARE GOING BALD.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED FIRST?
FIND OUT NEXT.
♪♪♪
I'M ONE OF THE 13
LOVELY LADIES
WHO ARE COMPETING
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND I'M VERY EXCITED TO BE HERE.
AND I'M EXCITED TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT.
(all scream)
DID YOU GUYS LIKE THAT?
IT'S KINDA FUN TO COME
CRASHING THROUGH.
MY HEART DROPPED
TO THE FLOOR,
AND I COULD NOT BREATHE!
OKAY, LADIES, IT'S TIME
TO GET THIS COMPETITION
UNDER WAY!
SO YOU GUYS REALLY READY
TO BRING IT
AND GET STARTED WITH THIS?
YEAH!
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO.
WE'RE GONNA START.
♪♪♪
YOU KNOW,
IN THE WORLD OF MODELING,
THE PRETTY GENE IS NOT ENOUGH,
SO REALLY,
WHAT'LL MAKE YOU STAND OUT
IS YOUR DYNAMIC PERSONALITY.
SO TO TALK TO YOU GIRLS
ABOUT STANDING OUT
AND PERSONALITY,
I COULDN'T THINK OF ANYBODY ELSE
THAN THE PERSONALITY FILLED
JANICE DICKINSON!
(all scream)
THAT'S ALL YOU GOT?
BE AFRAID.
BE VERY AFRAID.
(all screams)
PERHAPS I CAN GET INVOLVED.
I WANNA SEE SOME EXPRESSION
IN YOUR FACE!
ALRIGHT...
NO JANICE.
YOU KNOW WHY
I COINED THE TERM SUPERMODEL?
WHY?
'CAUSE I CAN.
AND YOU THOUGHT I WAS FINISHED.
JAY INTRODUCES
JANICE DICKENSON,
THE WORLD'S OLDEST SUPERMODEL.
SHE DOESN'T LOOK THAT OLD.
WELL, THIS IS WHAT
YOU HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT PERSONALITY.
PERSONALITY--
IT'S ABOUT FINDING
THAT ONE THING
INSIDE OF YOU THAT REGISTERS
WHAT IS GONNA SEPARATE ME FROM
HER, HER OR EVEN MR. JAY MANUEL.
SO ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THESE DOORS,
WE ACTUALLY HAVE
A PRESS CONFERENCE
SET UP FOR YOU.
THERE IS ONE MIKE ON EACH TABLE,
SO IT'S UP TO YOU GIRLS
TO BE HEARD.
SO YOU'RE EITHER GONNA BE
IN THE FOREFRONT OF ALL
THE PRESS REPORTERS' MINDS,
OR YOU'RE GONNA FADE
INTO THE BACKGROUND.
IT'S UP TO YOU TO DECIDE.
I'M FEELING A LITTLE BIT
NERVOUS, BECAUSE I CAN'T SPEAK
VERY WELL IN PUBLIC.
SO LET'S GO.
HIT IT, BITCHES!
♪♪♪
SITTING IN THE CHOICE SEAT
WAS A STRATEGIC MOVE
ON MY PART, OF COURSE.
I MEAN, IT'S ONLY 2 MIKES
FOR 13 GIRLS.
MY HEART IS BEATING, LIKE,
A MILLION MILES A MINUTE.
I WAS JUST, LIKE, SO SCARED,
BECAUSE THERE THEY ARE
JUST STARIN' AT US.
FIRST, AT THE END,
WE HAVE TODD NEWTON
WHO IS A TELEVISION
AND RADIO HOST.
WE HAVE TRISH MORENO WHO IS
A FASHION INDUSTRY PROFESSIONAL.
WE'VE GOT MISS ROLANDA WATTS
WHO IS A TV PERSONALITY,
TREY SMITH
WHO IS A SPECIAL CORRESPONDENT.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
WE'VE GOT TINA FRAZIER
WHO IS A NEWS REPORTER.
I'D LIKE TO START
THIS PRESS CONFERENCE
BY HEARING FROM THE YOUNG LADY
THAT TRULY FEELS
SHE'S THE FRONT RUNNER.
ME. ME.
ACTUALLY, I'VE BEEN HERE.
I GOT MY FIRST
THREE WORDS OUT,
AND I THINK DANIELLE
JUST SNATCHED THE MIKE
OUT OF MY HAND.
YES, I FEEL
LIKE I AM THE FRONT RUNNER
IN THIS COMPETITION,
AND I AM NOT GONNA LET SOME GIRL
THAT SIT NEXT TO ME,
BEHIND ME OR
DOWN THE WAY FROM ME TAKE THIS.
IT'S EVERY WOMAN FOR HERSELF.
EVERYBODY ELSE
COULD HAVE JUMPED UP, TOO,
BUT I BEAT 'EM TO THE PUNCH.
WELL, ACTUALLY,
UM, I HAVE THE BODY FOR IT,
THE ATTITUDE.
I'M THE FIERCE
FABULOUS FURONDA.
I'M THE FORERUNNER
FOR THIS COMPETITION.
THANK YOU, MISS FURONDA.
GIVE ME THE MIKE!
I FEEL I AM
THE UNDISCOVERED SUPERMODEL.
WHY?
WHAT MAKES YOU SO HOT?
I FEEL THAT I HAVE
THE MOST POTENTIAL.
I'M VERSATILE.
I'M TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
WE'RE ALL
GONNA HAVE TO TAKE NOTE OF THAT.
SHUT UP, UP THERE.
SHUT UP.
NOW ZIP IT
IS NICER THAN SHUT UP--ZIP IT.
BEING 26,
I SHOULD ALREADY HAVE BEEN
A TOP MODEL.
I FEEL LIKE I HAVE SO MUCH
DAMN POTENTIAL!
WHO'S THE BIGGEST FAKE?
(laughing)
I'M SORRY.
I'M SO SORRY.
I ALWAYS THINK IT'S ABOUT ME.
HOW WOULD YOU DEAL
WITH SOME OF THE BITCHES?
HOW I DEAL WITH CONFRONTATION,
IF YOU DON'T LIKE ME, DON'T
EVEN WASTE MY TIME BECAUSE
I'M NOT HERE TO MAKE FRIENDS.
I'M HERE TO WIN.
GOOD GOD, BROOKE.
KARI, MY CONCERN
IS WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM YOU.
ALSO, YOUR BASEBALL CAP'S
PULLED DOWN OVER YOUR EYES.
TAKE IT OFF, HONEY.
LOOK HOW GORGEOUS YOU ARE!
TAKE YOUR SHIRT OFF, TOO.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKIN' ABOUT!
WHO INSPIRED EVERYBODY
TO MODEL?
I WAS INSPIRED LOOKING AT TYRA
AND IMAN.
I LOOK UP TO STELLA TENNANT.
I JUST LOOK AT ALL OF HER ADS,
AND SHE SPEAKS TO ME.
I'M KIND OF CURIOUS TO HEAR
WHAT YOUR BIGGEST FEAR IS.
I'D LIKE TO SAY
THAT MY MIDDLE NAME IS FEARLESS.
YOU NEED TO GET RID
OF THAT ACCENT A LITTLE BIT.
I TRY AND LIVE MY LIFE
WITH THE MOTTO, "NO REGRETS."
AND I'M JUST SO EXCITED TO--
YAWN.
SORRY.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW,
WHO HAS SACRIFICED THE MOST
TO GET HERE WHERE YOU ARE TODAY?
I BELIEVE
I'VE LEFT THE MOST BEHIND.
I LEFT NIGERIA IN 1995.
EVEN THOUGH I WANTED TO BE
A MODEL AT 14 YEARS OLD,
I HAD TO SACRIFICE THAT GOAL,
AND I HAD TO SUPPORT
MY ENTIRE FAMILY
BACK HOME IN NIGERIA.
BUT I FEEL LIKE IF I WIN THIS,
IN THE LONG RUN,
THIS IS GONNA BE
VERY BENEFICIAL TO THEM.
BEST ANSWER OF THE WHOLE LOT,
RIGHT THERE, ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
MY STRATEGY HAS ALWAYS BEEN
TO JUST STAY TRUE TO WHO I AM
AND DON'T TRY
TO BE SO COMPETITIVE
THAT I BECOME SOMEBODY ELSE
AND GET LOST.
GINA, HOW DOES BEING
AN ASIAN WOMAN
FACTOR INTO YOUR DETERMINATION
TO WIN THIS COMPETITION?
I GUESS, I DON'T KNOW.
I JUST--I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION.
SO, GINA, WHEN YOU MET US
DURING CASTING WEEK,
THAT WAS THE FIRST THING
YOU MENTIONED.
SO WHY DO YOU WANT TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
THERE'S JUST NOT ENOUGH
ASIAN MODELS OUT THERE.
WHY IN A ROOM WITH ALL THESE
REPORTERS, WHY WOULD YOU
NOT TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO PUT IT IN THE FOREFRONT?
I'M JUST, I'M 21 YEARS OLD,
AND I DON'T KNOW
WHO I REALLY AM YET.
I'M KIND OF, LIKE, STRUGGLING.
I'M, LIKE,
HAVING AN IDENTITY CRISIS HERE.
GINA, SHE TENDS TO FOLD
UNDER PRESSURE.
I REALLY DIDN'T FEEL LIKE
I REPRESENTED MYSELF PROPERLY,
AND IT'S JUST
KIND OF REALLY OVERWHELMING.
LADIES, IF YOU CAN
ACTUALLY EXIT THE ROOM
FROM WHERE YOU CAME IN,
WE'RE ALL GONNA SIT AND DISCUSS
THIS PRESS CONFERENCE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD LUCK.
CAN I JUST ASK YOU SOMETHIN',
FOR REAL, GIRL?
YOU HAVE SOME INSECURITY
ABOUT YOUR RACE.
WHY DO YOU THINK I'M INSECURE,
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHO I AM?
AND EVEN YOU SAID IT YOURSELF
THAT YOU'RE A LITTLE LIKE...
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I THINK GINA MAKES HERSELF
AN EASY TARGET.
BECAUSE SHE'S SO VULNERABLE.
YOU CAN SAY SOMETHING TO HER
IN A MINUTE, AND HER
CONFIDENCE WILL GO WAY DOWN.
AS A KOREAN PERSON
AND AN AMERICAN PERSON,
I'M JUST A LITTLE BIT OF BOTH,
AND I DON'T KNOW WHICH ONE
I AM MORE OF.
I BELIEVE THAT GINA--
SHE'S NOT IN TOUCH WITH HERSELF.
I KNOW WHO I AM.
YOU KNOW, I'M BIRACIAL,
FOR GOD SAKES.
MY FATHER IS BLACK,
WHITE AND INDIAN.
AND MY MOTHER IS JUST
THIS REALLY EXOTIC WHITE WOMAN,
AND I LEARNED TO LIVE WITH IT.
I DON'T MEAN TO BRING YOU CRAP,
BUT SERIOUSLY, LIKE, YOU, LIKE--
TO BE IN THIS COMPETITION, YO,
YOU GOTTA KNOW WHO YOU ARE,
PERIOD.
JADE, SHE LIKES THE FACT
THAT GINA'S AFRAID OF HER
AND THAT SHE
CAN OVERPOWER SOMEONE
IN THIS COMPETITION
TO MAKE HER LOOK VERY STRONG.
HI.
HELLO.
WE WERE HAVING SEX.
JUST KIDDING!
WE WERE ACTUALLY
GOING OVER THE RESULTS.
THE PANEL HAD
AN OVERWHELMING OPINION
AS TO WHO SHOULD WIN
THIS CHALLENGE.
JANICE, I'M GONNA GIVE--
LET YOU DO THE HONORS.
YOU WANNA SAY WHO THE WINNER IS
OF THE CHALLENGE?
NNENNA!
GET OVER HERE, GIRLFRIEND!
WHOO-HOO!
I WAS CHOSEN
AS THE MOST IMPRESSIVE,
AND THAT MAKES ME FEEL
REALLY GOOD ABOUT MYSELF.
SO, NNENNA,
YOU GET TO PICK THREE FRIENDS.
PICK 'EM RIGHT NOW.
GINA, JADE, SARA.
ALL RIGHT.
WHERE WE ALL GOIN'?
YOU GIRLS GET A HEAD START
TO GET INTO THE HOUSE
THAT YOU'RE MOVING IN TONIGHT
TO PICK THE PLACE
WHERE YOU ARE GOING TO LIVE
THROUGH THIS COMPETITION.
AH, YES!
I'M REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT MOVING INTO THE HOUSE.
JUST HOPIN' I GET TO STAY THERE
LONG ENOUGH TO ENJOY IT,
AND I'M GONNA WORK MY HARDEST
TO DO SO.
♪♪♪
WHEW, BABY!
(screams)
ALL OF US TEAR INTO THE HOUSE
LIKE WILD WOMEN.
♪♪♪
WE'RE RUNNIN' IN,
AND WE'RE ALL LIKE, OH, MY GOD!
(screams)
BECAUSE THE FEEL OR OUR HOUSE
IS A MODELING AGENCY.
HOT.
YEAH, BABY!
THE BEDROOMS
EACH HAVE A THEME.
LIKE THE TWIGGY ROOM
HAS KIND OF A '60s MOD FEEL.
OH, MY GOSH!
THERE'S SOMETHIN' FROM YOURS
ON MINE.
TWIGGY'S SOMEONE
I HAVE LOOKED UP TO
AND PROBABLY THE MAIN REASON
I GOT INTO MODELING.
I'M IN LOVE.
I LOVE IT.
WHERE DO I GO?
I WENT TO THE FIRST ROOM,
AND I SEE IMAN'S PICTURE.
I WAS DONE.
I DIDN'T NEED TO SEE
ANY OTHER ROOM.
THERE'S A JANICE ROOM.
OF COURSE, HER ROOM IS ALL GLAM.
THIS CHICK IS HOT.
I WAS LIKE, THIS IS ME.
I ENVISION MYSELF AS JANICE.
YOU'RE A HOT BITCH.
BECAUSE SHE LOOKED LIKE
AN EXOTIC BIRACIAL BUTTERFLY,
LIKE MYSELF.
OH, MY GOD!
THERE IS A CHRISTI ROOM
WITH A SALTWATER FISHTANK,
AND IT JUST SEEMED SO COLORFUL
AND, LIKE, CHEERY.
THE CHRISTIE ROOM IS SO ME.
SHE'S BLOND, SHE'S BLUE-EYED,
THIS LIKE ALL-AMERICAN GIRL.
THE VERY END ROOM
OF THE HOUSE
DOESN'T REALLY HAVE
ONE SUPERMODEL THEME.
IT'S A COLLECTION OF THE PAST
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODELS.
NO WAY.
OH, MY GOD!
THERE'S PICTURES OF MODELS
EVERYWHERE.
OH, MAN, LOOK AT THIS.
WHOO!
FIRE!
I'M GONNA BE DOING THIS.
THAT'S MERCEDES.
I JUST WAS IN SHOCK AND AWE.
I DON'T EVEN HAVE WORDS TO
EXPLAIN LIKE WHERE I CAME FROM
AND WHERE I'M AT THIS WEEK,
LIKE, HOW YOUR LIFE
COULD CHANGE FOR THE BETTER.
THIS WAS A DREAM COME TRUE,
IT'S-- IT'S JUST AMAZING.
(laughing)
OUR MAIN COURTYARD IS GORGEOUS.
IT DOESN'T HAVE A ROOF.
WE HAVE, LIKE, VINES
AT THE TOP OF THE CEILING.
AND WE'RE ALL LIKE, OH, MY GOD!
THE CRIB IS JUST IMMACULATE.
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
WHOO!
EVERYONE MOVES IN, ALL THE GIRLS
WENT OUT TO DINNER.
♪♪♪
(excited chatter)
SO TODAY'S A REALLY HARD DAY.
AND THIS THING WITH ME AND JADE,
I'M JUST LETTING THE LITTLE
PETTY THINGS GET TO ME.
WANT SOME CHAMPAGNE?
♪♪♪
OH, MY GOD! SHE JUST
CHUGGED THE WHOLE THING.
GINA'S GONNA BE TWISTED!
SAY SOMETHIN' TO US.
I WANT TO GET ANOTHER ONE.
♪♪♪
GINA'S TWISTED OUT THERE.
I'LL DRINK IT SLOW THIS TIME.
WITH GINA DRINKING TOO MUCH,
I FELT BAD FOR HER THAT
SHE WENT TOO OVERBOARD.
THAT'S EMPTY.
THERE'S PLENTY.
GINA, KEEP YOUR EYES OPEN
AT ALL TIMES, GIRL.
I'VE NEVER SEEN SOMEONE THAT
DRUNK BEFORE.
SO IT REALLY SCARED ME.
I'M FEELING A LITTLE EMBARRASSED
AND, LIKE, A LITTLE HUMILIATED.
I KNOW I'M NEVER GONNA DRINK
ALCOHOL AGAIN.
♪♪♪
THERE SHE IS!
WHOO!
YEAH, BABY!
I DARE YOU.
KATHY!
COME IN HERE, BUTT ASS!
I LIKE CAME OUT THERE TO SEE
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
I WAS LIKE, OH, I SEE BOOBIES.
SO I DIDN'T REALLY FIT IN
BECAUSE I HAVE NONE.
I WILL GIVE SOMEBODY $40 IF THEY
CATWALK NAKED DOWN THE POOL.
LET'S GO GET IT RIGHT NOW.
I OFFERED NNENNA $100
TO DO THE RUNWAY
AROUND THE POOL NAKED.
I WANT YOU TO DO TYRA'S DRIPPING
FROM THE FINGERTIPS.
SORT OF BE LIKE SEXY, POSING.
NO COVERING OF THE BOOBIES,
NOTHING.
AROUND THE POOL AND BACK.
I'LL DO IT WITH YOU,
HOW ABOUT 50/50?
GINA'S LIKE, I'LL DO IT MYSELF.
SHE COMES OFF REALLY STRONG
AND REALLY CONFIDENT
AND KIND OF ARROGANT.
TWO FOR THE MONEY,
TWO FOR THE SHOW.
TWO TO GET READY
NOW FRIGGIN' WALK.
OF COURSE, JADE DOESN'T ACTUALLY
END UP DOING IT HERSELF.
JADE, SHE HAS THIS
FACADE OF STRENGTH.
BUT I SEE RIGHT THROUGH JADE.
♪♪♪
HELLO.
OH, MY GOD!
(screaming)
SO WELCOME, EVERYBODY!
HI!
Y'ALL ARE THE DOPEST 13
THAT AUDITIONED FOR THIS.
WELL, I JUST WANNA
CONGRATULATE YOU ALL,
BECAUSE I CHOSE EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF YOU.
YOU ALL ARE SPECIAL.
YOU ALL HAVE A UNIQUE BEAUTY.
IF YOU LOOK AT EACH OTHER,
NOBODY LOOKS LIKE ANYBODY ELSE.
DO YOU NOTICE THAT?
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, YOU ALL
ARE EACH OTHER'S COMPETITION.
ALL RIGHT, SO WHAT QUESTIONS DO
YOU GUYS HAVE FOR ME?
DO YOU HAVE ANY TIPS FOR, LIKE,
LOOKING IN THE MIRROR
AND DOING A BUNCH OF VARIETY
WITH YOUR FACE?
CHANGING YOUR FACIAL
EXPRESSION-- IT'S ABOUT
HOW TO PULL YOUR CHEEKBONES
UP JUST USING THE MUSCLE.
HOW TO PULL ONE EYEBROW UP,
WHICH IS A GREAT
CHRISTY TURLINGTON MOVE THAT
I STILL CAN'T DO.
DO YOU HAVE ANY TIPS FOR, UM,
LIKE, HOW TO BE YOURSELF
AT PRESS SORT OF SITUATIONS?
JUST PRETEND LIKE THEY'RE
PEOPLE THAT YOU KNOW.
LIKE, ASK ME ANY QUESTION,
AND I'LL PRETEND
LIKE I'M HAVIN' AN INTERVIEW.
I'LL ANSWER IT THE WRONG WAY
AND THE GOOD WAY.
BE GOOFY, SHOW US YOU'RE GOOFY.
OKAY, THIS IS A BAD EXAMPLE.
BE GOOFY, UM...
OKAY.
(laughing)
IS THAT GOOFY?
THAT'S BAD.
DO IT AGAIN.
BE GOOFY,
SHOW US GOOFY RIGHT NOW.
OH, YOU WANT ME TO BE GOOFY?
OKAY, HEY!
HEY!
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
YOU JUST GO FOR IT
AND JUST DO IT.
YOU GOT A QUESTION, FURONDA?
UM, WHAT TIPS WOULD YOU HAVE
FOR THE GIRLS HERE
THAT ARE GONNA BE ELIMINATED?
YOU SHOULDN'T BE ASKIN'
THAT QUESTION ANYWAY.
WHY YOU ASKIN' THAT QUESTION?
I'M SAYIN' FOR ELIMINATED GIRLS.
I DON'T HAVE THAT TIP,
I DON'T GIVE THOSE TIPS.
FURONDA SEEMS TO PUT ON AN ACT,
BUT SHE'S ALWAYS, LIKE, YOU
KNOW, I'M THE PRINCESS.
I'M GONNA WIN.
SHE KINDA SEEMS THE ONE THAT'S
KINDA LIKE
THE BADASS IN THE HOUSE.
SOMEONE'S GOING HOME,
BUT SOME PEOPLE
MAY NEED TO WORRY MORE THAN ME.
I'M GONNA BE THE WINNER, MM-HMM.
I JUST HAD GIRLS THAT ASKED ME,
SO I REALLY WANTED YOU
TO ANSWER FOR THEM.
YEAH?
EVERYBODY'S LIKE, "WHAT?!"
AIN'T NOBODY ASKED YOU NOTHIN'!
AND IT KINDA RAISED
A EYEBROW WITH TYRA.
WELL, I'M OUTTA HERE.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, SEE YA LATER.
BYE.
BYE-BYE.
♪♪♪
WE HAVE TYRA MAIL!
HO-HO!
LET ME READ WHAT IT SAYS.
"TYRA MAIL.
LET'S CUT TO THE CHASE."
YEAH, I THINK
IT'S ELIMINATION TIME.
MAYBE WE'RE RUNNING
SOMEWHERE, CHASING.
SO WE'RE JUST, LIKE,
ALL TRYIN' TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THIS MAIL COULD MEAN.
CUT HAIR-- CUT.
OH! OH!
MAKEOVER TIME.
WE'RE ALL GONNA GET REDONE.
♪♪♪
WE ARRIVE AT
THE WARREN-TRICOMI SALON,
LIKE, YES! YOU KNOW,
CUT TO THE CHASE--
THIS MEANS MAKEOVERS!
HEY!
GOOD MORNING!
GOOD MORNING.
SO OBVIOUSLY, TODAY WE'RE HERE
AT THE WARREN-TRICOMI SALON
HERE IN LOS ANGELES FOR?
MAKEOVERS!
MAKEOVERS-- YOU GUYS EXCITED?
YES!
WELL, TODAY, I HAVE A VERY
SPECIAL GUEST TO HELP ME OUT.
SHE'S ACTUALLY PROBABLY ONE OF
THE COOLEST MODELS
AND WORKS WITH ALL THE BIG
DESIGNERS.
EVE, COME ON OUT HERE.
HELLO!
YOU KNOW, EVE GOT HER START
ON THE RUNWAYS
WITH MY FAVORITE DESIGNER,
JEAN PAUL GAULTIER.
YOU WANNA TELL THEM
A BIT ABOUT IT?
WELL, I SHAVED MY HEAD,
AND HE DISCOVERED ME.
SO THERE'S A REASON
WE HAVE EVE HERE TODAY.
YOU GIRLS ARE GOIN' BALD.
(sighing)
WHAT?
WE THOUGHT WE'D JUST KINDA
EVEN OUT THE PLAYING FIELD,
SEE WHO REALLY CAN BRING
THEIR BEAUTY FROM WITHIN.
YOU GIRLS ARE GOIN' BALD.
WE DON'T HAVE
HAIRDRESSERS TODAY.
IT'S JUST US AND SOME CLIPPERS.
A BALDY.
BALD.
SHAVED OFF.
GINA, YOU LOOK
A LITTLE SHOCKED OVER THERE.
I TRIED TO PICTURE
MY HEAD BALD,
AND I COULDN'T DO IT.
I'M SCARED.
KATHERINE, YOU GOT
THE LONGEST HAIR HERE PROBABLY.
UH, YEAH.
I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS.
JUST A LITTLE.
I'M REALLY SHOCKED.
WHAT ARE THEY GONNA DO FOR
THE REST OF THE PHOTO SHOOTS?
ARE THEY GONNA GIVE US WIGS?
YOU GIRLS ARE GOING BALD
TODAY BECAUSE YOU'RE
GONNA BE WEARING BALD CAPS
FOR YOUR FIRST BIG PHOTO SHOOT.
(screams)
JADE, I THINK--
DID YOU PASS OUT?
NO.
I'M OKAY, BABY.
I WAS LIKE, "THANK YOU, JESUS."
BECAUSE I NEED HAIR.
SO I NEED YOU GIRLS
TO HEAD ON BACK OUT TO YOUR
CARS, AND I'M GONNA MEET YOU
OVER AT THE STUDIO, ALL RIGHT?
♪♪♪
IT'S NOT THAT EASY TO SHOOT
WITH BALD HEAD.
IT LOOKS PRETTY EASY,
BUT YOUR EMOTIONS WILL SHOW
WAY MORE THAN WITH THE HAIR.
SO A LITTLE MOVEMENT
CAN CHANGE THE WHOLE EMOTION
IN THE PICTURES.
WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU GIRLS
THAT SAME CHALLENGE.
SO YOU READY?
YEAH!
SO LET'S HEAD BACK OVER
TO MAKEUP.
IT'S A VERY LONG PROCESS,
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO PUT,
LIKE, ALL MY HAIR
IN THIS, LIKE, BALD CAP.
IT FEELS TIGHT.
WE ARE GETTIN' BALD.
YEAH.
LIKE OLD-MAN-
LOSIN'-HAIR BALD.
THEY PAINTED OUR HEADS
SO WE LOOKED BALD,
AND IT REALLY, REALLY LOOKED
LIKE WE WERE BALD.
IT WAS KIND OF FREAKY.
YEAH, IT'S AMAZING,
'CAUSE IT LOOKS SO REAL, RIGHT?
IT'S AMAZING.
IT TRULY IS.
YOU HAVE A NICE SHAPE.
THANK YOU, I WORKED ON IT.
OH, I LOVE IT.
WE ARE GONNA BE DECORATED
WITH SWAROVSKI CRYSTALS.
I DON'T LOOK TOO BAD
AS A BALD CHICK.
THAT'S KINDA HOT.
HOW AM I GONNA POSE
WHEN I CAN'T MOVE MY NECK?
NO, YOU CAN MOVE YOUR NECK.
THERE'S SOME-- THERE'S SOME
ODD-LOOKIN' GIRLS OUT THERE.
MY LOOK RIGHT NOW
IS KIND OF FREAKY,
BUT I REALLY LIKE IT.
BUT I DO KIND OF FEEL
LIKE A PENIS WITH EARS.
UGH!
FEEL SPONTANEOUS.
LOWER YOUR HAND A LITTLE BIT.
YEAH, RAISE YOUR HEAD.
YOUR EYES DOWN, LOOK DOWN.
OKAY.
IT'S A LITTLE VACANT.
OKAY, KATHY, I NEED A
LITTLE MORE WARMTH IN THE FACE.
JUST TRY IT FOR ME, RIGHT THERE.
OKAY, NOW YOU LOOK
LIKE YOU JUST FARTED.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE, ALL RIGHT?
GOOD TO GO.
LOOK AT ME.
WHEN I ASKED KATHY
TO WARM UP HER EXPRESSION--
LOOK AT ME.
SHE DIDN'T KNOW
HOW TO DO THAT.
SO SHE KINDA WENT
FROM THIS SQUINTY LOOK
TO OOPS, I'M A DEER
CAUGHT IN THE HEADLIGHTS.
I REALLY DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT I WAS DOING.
OKAY, KATHY, YOU'RE DONE.
ALL RIGHT.
BUT, I MEAN,
IT WAS MY FIRST PHOTO SHOOT.
LESLIE, SO BASICALLY,
WE'RE SHOOTING FROM BUSTLINE UP.
OKAY.
AND I NEED TO SEE
THAT VULNERABILITY
COMING FROM INSIDE.
ALL RIGHT,
PLAY WITH YOUR HANDS.
LOOKS BEAUTIFUL.
BEAUTIFUL.
THAT'S REALLY ELEGANT.
IT IS GORGEOUS.
LESLIE JUST TURNED
INTO THIS MODEL.
SHE WAS ALL GRACEFUL,
AND I JUST SAT BACK
AND WATCHED THE MAGIC HAPPEN.
RAISE YOUR HEAD A LITTLE BIT.
OKAY, GOOD.
JUST MORE, MORE.
INTERESTING WITH KARI, WHEN
SHE GOT IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
KARI INSTANTLY
WENT INTO THOSE SAFE POSES.
I THINK YOU NEED TO DO THINGS
A LITTLE MORE OFF.
OKAY.
I NEED AWKWARD,
WEIRD, STUCK-UP.
OKAY.
THAT'S PERFECT.
DON'T MOVE LIKE THAT.
OOH, THAT ONE'S REALLY COOL.
MORE, MORE, MORE,
RAISE YOUR HEAD.
THAT'S GREAT.
THAT'S IT, LAST FRAME.
GREAT.
YEAH.
HOT MAMA.
I'M BALD, BEAUTIFUL AND BLINGY,
SO I KNOW I'M GONNA ROCK IT.
I WAS WATCHING FURONDA
PRACTICE IN THE MIRROR,
WHICH IS WHAT I LOOK FOR
IN AN ATTENTIVE, GOOD MODEL.
YOU WAS TALKIN' ABOUT ME
UP IN THE PRESS CONFERENCE
THE OTHER DAY.
PLAY WITH YOUR NECK.
EXTEND ALL YOUR BODY.
MORE, MORE, MORE.
LEAN-- MORE, MORE, MORE.
MORE TO THE SIDE.
THE OTHER WAY.
SLOWLY, SLOWLY, SLOWLY.
MUCH TO MY SURPRISE,
WHEN FURONDA GOT IN FRONT
OF THE CAMERA,
SHE WAS NOT ONLY AWKWARD,
SHE REALLY DIDN'T KNOW
HER ANGLES.
I THINK I DID GREAT.
I WAS COMIN' OFF
THINKIN' I WAS THE WINNER.
I AM THE FRONT RUNNER.
THANK YOU.
WHEN I SAW HER IN THE MIRROR
PRACTICING, I THOUGHT SHE WAS
GONNA BE, LIKE, AMAZING.
I THINK SHE THOUGHT
SHE WAS GONNA NAIL IT,
AND SHE DIDN'T.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT VICTIM.
VERY GOOD.
BEAUTIFUL.
I'M JUST HAVING SUCH A HARD TIME
AND LIKE THE STRANGE POSITIONS
AND POSES I WAS IN.
OKAY, GREAT.
OOH.
MOLLY, YOU KNOW THE HAND
THAT'S ON YOUR CHEST?
IT'S GONE, OKAY?
IT LOOKS LIKE A SLAB OF MEAT
LAYIN' UP AGAINST YOUR CHEST.
I'M LIKE I DON'T KNOW
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
THAT'S ONE THING
THAT KINDA BOTHERED ME
IS I COULD'VE DONE BETTER.
SARA, WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I DON'T HAVE ANY
MODELING EXPERIENCE.
IT DEFINITELY
PUT THE PRESSURE ON TODAY.
THAT'S GREAT.
VERY NICE.
OH, YES.
YEAH, THAT'S GOOD.
YOU IMPROVISED THERE.
THAT'S GREAT.
OKAY, I HATE
TO INTERRUPT YOU.
WHERE THE HELL
DID THIS COME FROM?
THIS IS ME, JAY.
THIS IS YOU?
I HAVEN'T LET ME OUT YET.
GIVE ME FIVE,
'CAUSE THIS-- THIS IS FIERCE.
EXACTLY.
EXCELLENT.
BEAUTIFUL.
THAT BITCH TURNED IT OUT,
SO YOU NEED TO, LIKE, REPRESENT
UP IN HERE.
I'M SURE GONNA TRY.
OKAY.
DANIELLE, I LOVE THE ASYMMETRY
OF THE HANDS.
SHE'S KILLIN' IT.
WELL, SHE'S GORGEOUS,
LIKE, FLAWLESS.
YOU LOOKIN' KINDA REGAL
UP IN THERE, GIRL.
JAY IS LIKE YOU LOOK REGAL.
I DID NOT KNOW WHAT REGAL MEANT.
SO I AIN'T SAY NOTHIN',
'CAUSE I WAS LIKE, IF IT'S BAD,
I DON'T WANNA BE LIKE THANK YOU.
IT'S A MORE HIGH FASHION,
SO DON'T DO THINGS
THAT ARE SAFE.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S IT.
OKAY, OPEN UP.
RAISE YOUR HEAD.
GINA LOOKED LIKE
A DEER CAUGHT IN HEADLIGHTS
IN EVERY FRAME.
OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHEN I TALK TO YOU,
IF I COULD HAVE THAT EXPRESSION.
PUT A THOUGHT IN YOU HEAD,
BASICALLY.
MOVE IN A BIT MORE
AND RAISE YOUR HEAD.
THIS IS THE FIRST CHALLENGE,
AND I DON'T FEEL
LIKE I DID POORLY.
ALL RIGHT, GINA,
YOU'RE A WRAP.
BUT STILL, I FEEL
THAT I COULD'VE DONE BETTER.
GINA-- I JUST DON'T THINK
SHE HAS THE CONFIDENCE.
TURN YOUR HEAD TOWARD ME.
ONE, TWO, VERY NICE.
DON'T LOOK AT ME.
NICE.
KEEP MOVING LIKE THAT.
BROOKE, A LOT OF TIMES
IF YOU LIFT YOUR HEAD TOO HIGH,
YOUR JAW LOOKS REALLY, REALLY,
REALLY BIG.
OH, OKAY.
GREAT.
KEEP GOING.
KEEP IMPROVISING.
LAST FRAME, BROOKE.
YOU READY?
COME ON.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S
REALLY INTERESTING?
JOANIE LOOKED LIKE
ONE OF THE MANNEQUINS ON SET,
BECAUSE JOANIE DIDN'T EVOKE
ANY EMOTION,
AND THAT'S NOT A GOOD THING.
NNENNA HAS BEEN KICKIN' ASS,
AND SHE LOOKS REALLY, REALLY,
REALLY GOOD BALD.
WE NEED HER LIST
OF ALLERGIES, PLEASE.
I'VE ALREADY ASKED HER
WHAT HER ALLERGIES ARE
SO I CAN KNOCK HER OUT
OF THE COMPETITION.
YOU TRYIN' TO KILL THE GIRL?
VERY BEAUTIFUL.
BEAUTIFUL.
NNENNA IS A BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
THAT'S GREAT.
SHE HAS THIS REGAL PRESENCE.
WHEN SHE WALKS IN A ROOM,
YOU EXPECT NNENNA
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
OKAY, NNENNA, THAT'S IT.
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL
AND I MOVED TO NEW YORK TO TRY
TO PURSUE A MODELING DREAM.
AND BEING HERE,
I AM SO EXCITED
TO BE SHOOTING WITH, YOU KNOW,
A WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER.
YOUR EYES, STRAIGHT.
DON'T MOVE TOO FAST.
CLOSE YOUR LIPS.
DON'T MOVE, DON'T MOVE.
OOH!
JADE, I WANT YOU TO SOFTEN IT UP
JUST A LITTLE BIT.
SORRY.
'CAUSE IT'S COMING OFF
A LITTLE HARD.
THIS IS GREAT.
OH, THAT'S NICE.
IT'S ACTUALLY KINDA DIFFICULT
WHEN YOU'RE WORKIN' WITH A GIRL
WHO THINKS
SHE'S A MODEL ALREADY.
DON'T COVER YOUR EYES TOO MUCH.
BECAUSE SHE'S GOT
WHAT SHE THINKS IS IT
AND EVERYONE'S MISSED HER.
MAYBE THERE'S A REASON.
I'M A STAR.
I KNOW I CAN DO "VOGUE," "W,"
"VICTORIA'S SECRET," "GQ."
I'M READY.
ALL RIGHT, JADE, YOU'RE DONE.
GOOD.
WE WRAPPED THAT OUT.
WHY WAS THAT HARDER
THAN I THOUGHT?
TYRA MAIL.
(screams)
WHAT DOES IT SAY, BABY GIRL?
"TOMORROW,
YOU WILL HAVE YOUR FIRST MEETING
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 12 WILL CONTINUE ON
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
SOMEBODY HAS TO GO HOME
FROM OUR BEAUTIFUL HOUSE.
IN THE 13 GIRLS
THAT WE HAVE HERE,
SOMEONE'S LEAVING.
HOW YA DOIN'?
I FEEL, LIKE,
INCREDIBLY NAUSEOUS RIGHT NOW.
I KNOW I CAN DO A LOT BETTER.
SO HOPEFULLY
I WON'T GET ELIMINATED,
AND HOPEFULLY, YOU KNOW,
I'LL JUST KEEP LEARNING
FROM MY MISTAKES.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHERE I STAND,
BUT I THOUGHT I DID OKAY.
BUT IT'S ALMOST, LIKE, CRAP.
SOMEONE IS GOING HOME.
♪♪♪
WELCOME TO YOUR
VERY FIRST JUDGING.
YOU'VE ALL DONE AN AMAZING JOB,
SO FAR,
BUT ONE OF YOU IS WEAKER
THAN THE OTHER 12.
AND ONE OF YOU
IS GOING HOME TONIGHT.
WE HAVE SOME AMAZING PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH A TOP MANAGEMENT COMPANY--
FORD MODELS--
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
SHOT BY WORLD-RENOWNED
PHOTOGRAPHER AND THE MAN
THAT STARTED MY CAREER--
GILLES BENSIMON--
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST,
THE NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
NIGEL BARKER.
HI, LADIES.
HELLO.
THE LEGENDARY RUNWAY COACH,
MS. J. ALEXANDER.
13 HERE, 1 TO GO.
AND FASHION ICON
AND LIVING LEGEND TWIGGY.
HELLO, LADIES.
HI.
GOOD LUCK.
FOR YOUR VERY FIRST
PHOTO SHOOT,
YOU HAD TO POSE BALD.
SO TONIGHT WE'LL BE JUDGING YOU
ON YOUR PHOTO SHOOT,
AND I'LL ALSO BE TALKING
WITH SOME OF YOU
ABOUT YOUR
PRESS CONFERENCE CHALLENGE.
ALL RIGHTY, THE FIRST GIRL
ON THE CHOPPING BLOCK IS SARA.
ALL RIGHT, SARA,
SO YOU HAD TO POSE BALD.
LET US SEE YOUR VERY FIRST SHOT.
WOW.
YOU LOOK LIKE
SOME WONDERFUL CREATURE
FROM ANOTHER PLANET.
IT'S DEVINE.
IT'S CALLED
THE PLANET OF BEAUTY.
THIS IS THE GIRL
THAT DIDN'T EVEN KNOW REALLY
ABOUT MODELING
AND WE FOUND IN A MALL?
THIS IS ONE OF THE BEST PICTURES
IN TOP MODEL HISTORY,
IN MY OPINION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHTY, DANIELLE.
SO, DANIELLE,
WHAT WENT THROUGH YOUR MIND
WHEN YOU KNEW
THAT YOU HAD TO POSE BALD?
I WAS KIND OF NERVOUS,
'CAUSE I HAVE DENTS IN MY HEAD
FROM GETTING MY HAIR PRESSED
WHEN I WAS YOUNGER.
OH, WOW.
OKAY, WELL, LET'S SEE
IF YOU HAVE ANY DENTS
IN YOUR HEAD.
THAT'S A VERY--
THAT'S A VERY GOOD DENT
IN YOUR HEAD.
WITH YOUR FACE-- FACIAL
FEATURES, WITH THE LIPS,
BUT HERE, IT'S LIKE
A MUCH PRETTIER VERSION
OF GRACE JONES.
THE ONE COMMENT I HAVE TO SAY
ABOUT YOU, DANIELLE,
IN GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM
IS YOU HAVE TO WATCH YOUR NOSE.
WHEN YOU GO UP TOO HIGH--
YOU SEE ALL UP IN THERE.
THERE YOU GO.
ALL RIGHTY, UP NEXT IS JADE.
IT'S A VERY STRIKING PICTURE
OF YOU,
BUT I DON'T SEE ANYTHING
PARTICULARLY MAGICAL.
YOU KNOW
WHAT YOUR PROBLEM IS.
YOU HAVE TO WATCH
YOUR BONE STRUCTURE,
BECAUSE AT TIMES, YOU CAN GET
A LITTLE"DRAGALICIOUS."
YES.
EVERYBODY WANTS
BONE STRUCTURE, AND YOU HAVE IT.
SO IT'S UP TO YOU TO WORK IT
AND MAKE IT RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT,
YOU HAD A PRESS PANEL.
YES.
AND THEY SAID
THAT YOU WERE VERY ARROGANT.
WHICH IS TOTALLY NOT TRUE.
YEAH, I FEEL I AM
THE UNDISCOVERED SUPERMODEL.
I'M VERSATILE.
I'M TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
I HAVE THE MOST POTENTIAL.
YOU DON'T THINK
YOU'RE ARROGANT AT ALL, JADE?
NO.
EVERY TIME I WALK
DOWN THE STREET,
HEADS ARE LIKE TURNIN',
LIKE LOOK AT THIS--
HUMILITY SHE DOES NOT LACK.
I'M VERY HUMBLE.
I'M VERY DOWN TO EARTH.
WELL, THAT'S WHAT
I WAS ABOUT TO SAY-- HUMBLE.
YES, I AM HUMBLE.
PART OF BEING HUMBLE
IS BEING QUIET--
WELL, HUMBLE INSIDE, I MEAN.
LISTENING--
NIGEL, I MEAN HUMBLE INSIDE.
AND NOT TALKING
OVER THE JUDGES.
ALL RIGHTY, THANKS, JADE.
UP NEXT IS JOANIE.
THOSE EYES!
WOW, THEY'RE LIKE LASERS.
WHEN YOU STRIP SOMEONE DOWN
TO JUST BARE ESSENTIALS,
YOU'RE A SURPRISE
WAITING TO HAPPEN.
THIS SOCKED ME IN THE FACE
AT HOW BEAUTIFUL IT WAS.
THANKS.
UP NEXT IS GINA.
I KNEW YOU WERE ACTUALLY
GONNA TURN OUT FANTASTIC
BECAUSE OF YOUR
HIGH CHEEK BONES.
IT WAS JUST HIDING
BEHIND THAT HAIR
WAITING TO COME OUT.
IN FACT,
PUT YOUR HAIR BEHIND YOU EARS,
SO WE CAN SEE YOUR FACE.
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
THAT'S MORE OF A MODEL.
THAT OTHER HAIR DOWN
IS LIKE A GIRL IN A MALL.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT IS MOLLIE SUE.
MOLLY, THIS PICTURE OF YOU
IS ABSOLUTELY STUNNING,
BUT ONE THING
I WAS DISAPPOINTED WITH--
YOUR FILM IN GENERAL
WASN'T STRONG.
YOU TEND TO SQUINT,
THINKING THAT'S INTENSITY.
EVERY NOW AND THEN YOU HIT IT
AND GET THIS,
BUT SOMETIMES IS JUST LOOKS LIKE
THIS SMILE THING YOU DO
AND LIKE A SQUINT.
YEP.
UP NEXT IS FURONDA.
PERSONALLY, FURONDA,
THIS IS NOT
MY FAVORITE PHOTOGRAPH.
IT'S AN INTERESTING SHOT,
ALMOST LIKE AN ART PIECE.
BUT REALITY IS THIS IS MODELING
WE'RE TRYING TO DO,
AND IT HAS TO LEND ITSELF
TO BEING PRETTY, TOO.
THOSE EYES,
THEY PIERCE YOU, DON'T THEY?
YOU HAVE THE MOST BEAUTIFUL,
FAR-APART EYES
THAT ARE VERY GOOD FOR A MODEL,
BUT YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO WITH THEM YET.
UP NEXT IS WENDY.
YOU LOOK A BIT SAD TO ME.
THERE'S NO CONNECTION FOR ME.
WHAT I ACTUALLY ENJOY
ABOUT YOUR PHOTOGRAPH
IS THE FACT THAT THE SADNESS
THAT SEEMS TO BE IN YOUR EYES
IS, IN FACT, AN EMOTION,
THAT THERE IS SOMETHING THERE.
THANK YOU.
UP NEXT IS NNENNA.
ARE YOU WORKING IT, NNENNA?
SINCE THE MOMENT SHE ARRIVED,
RIGHT?
ALL RIGHT, NNENNA,
SO YOU WERE ACTUALLY
THE CHALLENGE WINNER.
NNENNA!
WHOO-HOO!
CONGRATULATIONS.
WELL DONE.
LOVELY.
NNENNA, THIS PICTURE--
ABSOLUTELY FABULOUS.
YOUR STRENGTH IS YOUR ANGLES.
IT'S JUST A GOOD PICTURE
OF A BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
NEXT IS KATHY.
ALL RIGHTY,
THE PRESS PEOPLE SAID
THAT THERE WAS SOMETHING COOL
ABOUT YOU THAT THEY LIKE,
BUT THAT YOU HAVE TO WORK
ON THAT SOUTHERN ACCENT
AND THAT YOU HAVE
TERRIBLE POSTURE.
TERRIBLE POSTURE?
YEAH.
I HAVE TO AGREE WITH THEM.
RELAX YOUR ARMS.
BACK.
HEAD UP.
AH.
AND NOW BREATHE.
OH, OH,
THERE'S A MODEL RIGHT THERE.
SHE WENT AWAY,
BUT SHE WAS THERE FOR A SECOND.
SHE'LL COME BACK.
I PROMISE.
ALL RIGHTY, KATHY.
SO LET'S SEE IF YOU WORKED
WITH NO HAIR ON YOUR HEAD.
WHAT DO YOU SEE WRONG
ABOUT THE PICTURE?
I THINK I COULD HAVE FOCUSED
MY EYES A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD.
THEY'RE NOT FOCUSED ON ANYTHING.
IT'S LIKE A DEAD PHOTOGRAPH.
THERE'S NO--FOR ME, NO LIFE.
AND IT'S SAD,
BECAUSE THERE'S
SO MUCH POTENTIAL.
THE SHAPE OF YOU HEAD,
BUT EVERYBODY'S RIGHT.
THE EYES-- NOTHING.
NEXT IS KARI.
ALL RIGHTY, SO LET'S SEE
WHAT YOU LOOK LIKE.
KARI, ACTUALLY,
I THINK YOU LOOK RATHER ANGELIC
IN THIS PICTURE.
THESE INCREDIBLE BIG EYES,
LIKE SAUCERS.
YOU'VE GOT A GREAT FACE.
UM, I LOVE THIS PICTURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LESLIE.
WOW, I THINK
IT'S VERY PRETTY.
I WOULDN'T
HAVE RECOGNIZED YOU
FROM THAT PHOTOGRAPH.
YOU COMPLETELY CHANGED,
WHICH IS GOOD.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU
GOT INSPIRED BY THE GREEN MAKEUP
IN THE PICTURE
AND PUT IT ON TODAY,
BUT THAT'S WAY TOO MUCH MAKEUP
FOR YOU.
YOU'RE A BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
YOU DON'T NEED ALL THAT.
THANK YOU.
AND LAST, BUT NOT LEAST
IS BROOKE.
I'M VERY, VERY DISAPPOINTED
IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH,
'CAUSE I CAN'T SEE YOU.
YOU JUST BLENDED RIGHT IN
WITH THE"MANNECAN'TS."
NOT THE MANNEQUINS,
THEMANNECAN'TS.
THE REASON WHY THIS PHOTO
WAS CHOSEN FOR YOU
IS BECAUSE YOU HAVE A BIG CHIN
WHEN YOU WERE STRAIGHT ON.
SO YOU HAVE TO GET IN THE MIRROR
AND FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MAKE YOUR PHOTOS
NOT LOOK LIKE THIS.
ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES
TO DETERMINE YOUR FATE.
TIME FOR US TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
THE FIRST GIRL
WILL BE GOING HOME.
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR US
TO DELIBERATE,
'CAUSE SOMEBODY'S GOTTA GO HOME,
UNFORTUNATELY.
NNENNA.
OKAY, WELL, BOTTOM LINE,
NNENNA HAS THE FACE OF A MODEL,
THE BODY OF A MODEL,
REALLY INCREDIBLE FACE.
WELL, I ACTUALLY THINK
NNENNA IS RATHER WONDERFUL.
BROOKE.
THAT IS A DREADFUL PICTURE
OF BROOKE.
BUT I THINK SHE'S BETTER
THAN THE PICTURE.
BROOKE IS DEFINITELY STUNNING.
SHE'S THE KIND OF BEAUTY
THAT PEOPLE ON THE STREET
WON'T NECESSARILY UNDERSTAND
BECAUSE OF THE EXAGGERATION
OF HER FEATURES,
BUT THAT EXAGGERATION
IS WHAT MAKES HER A MODEL.
DANIELLE.
NOW DANIELLE
JUST STUCK OUT FOR ME
FROM THE MOMENT I SAW HER--
EXTRAORDINARY, REGAL,
THAT BONE STRUCTURE,
WOW, IT WORKS.
GINA.
THERE'S NOT REALLY ANYTHING
IN THESE EYES.
WHAT YOU HAVE HERE IS BONES.
QUESTION IS,
DOES SHE HAVE THE PERSONALITY?
I THINK MOLLIE'S PERSONALITY
IS FLAT.
SHE DOESN'T DO IT FOR ME.
THERE'S SOMETHING VERY SEXY
ABOUT MOLLIE SUE.
KATHY.
IT'S NOT A MODEL'S FACE.
IN EVERY HOMETOWN,
THERE ARE GIRLS
THAT LOOK LIKE KATHY.
I THINK
THAT SHE PHOTOGRAPHS WELL.
I REALLY DO.
KATHY'S A HILLBILLY
WITH A PHILOSOPHY.
WHAT'S HER PHILOSOPHY?
I THINK I CAN
WIN THIS COMPETITION
JUST BEIN' SWEET, SOUTHERN
AND A BIT DIFFERENT.
SARA.
♪ LOVE SARA ♪
THIS IS MY 6"1'
SCARLETT JOHANSSON.
SHE'S DEVINE.
JOANIE.
WHAM, THIS GIRL'S A MODEL.
THIS IS SO STRONG.
I DON'T SEE THAT IN FRONT OF ME.
HOPEFULLY SHE CAN BE THIS
IN PERSON.
FURONDA.
HER NAME IS QUITE FEROCIOUS.
I DO NOT LIKE THIS PICTURE
OF FURONDA,
BUT I THINK THERE'S SOMETHIN'
IN THIS GIRL,
BUT IT AIN'T IN THIS PICTURE.
IT'S LIKE,
"FURONDA, CALL HOME."
I MEAN, IT'S VERY ALIEN.
LESLIE.
SHE'S GOT BEAUTIFUL EYES.
SHE'S QUITE EXOTIC,
BUT HER HANDS LOOK A BIT SCALY.
LIKE SHE NEEDS SOME LOTION.
KARI.
KARI'S GONE FROM GOLDILOCKS
TO"BALDILOCKS."
QUITE FRANKLY,
THIS LOOK ON HER IS NOT WORKING.
I LIKE KARI'S MOUTH.
THAT MOUTH SAVES HER
AND THOSE BIG EYES.
WENDY.
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT WENDY
IS THAT THE SADNESS IN THE EYES,
I HAVEN'T SEEN THIS
ON "TOP MODEL" BEFORE.
I THINK YOU SHOULD UNDERSTAND
WHAT HER SADNESS COMES FROM.
WENDY LIVES IN NEW ORLEANS.
SHE WAS ONE OF THE PEOPLE
WHO LOST EVERYTHING.
OH, MY GOD!
IS SHE STRONG ENOUGH
AT THIS POINT
TO GO THROUGH THIS, YOU THINK?
I THINK SHE IS.
JADE.
JADE-- SHE SCARED ME.
JADE IS A BIT TRANNY TO ME,
AND THAT'S WHY I LOVE HER.
I WONDER WHY
SHE FEELS THE NEED
TO CONSTANTLY SAY
HOW AMAZING SHE IS.
NOT ONLY
TRYING TO CONVINCE OTHERS,
BUT YOU'RE TRYING
TO CONVINCE YOURSELF.
I THINK
IF CONCEITED DRAG QUEEN IS IN,
THEN PERHAPS SHE HAS A FUTURE
IN MODELING.
LA JADE.
♪♪♪
13 BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE 12 PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE 12 OF YOU THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
NNENNA.
CONGRATULATIONS, NNENNA.
YOU TOOK A STUNNING PHOTO,
AND YOU WON THE CHALLENGE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
SARA.
SARA, THIS PHOTO IS MAGICAL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
LESLIE.
JOANIE.
KARI.
DANIELLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
JADE.
MISS MOLLIE SUE.
BROOKE.
GINA.
WORK THE RUNWAY, GIRL.
CONGRATULATIONS, GINA.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
WENDY.
CONGRATULATIONS, WENDY.
THANK YOU.
WILL FURONDA AND KATHY
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL ONLY CALL ONE NAME,
AND THE NAME THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO THE HOUSE,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS,
AND GO HOME.
FURONDA, YOU THOUGHT
THAT YOU DID AN AMAZING JOB
IN YOUR PHOTO SHOOT.
YOU THOUGHT YOU ROCKED IT.
YOU THOUGHT YOU DID BETTER
THAN ALL THOSE GIRLS
IN THIS ENTIRE ROOM.
SOME OF THE JUDGES
THINK YOU DID THE WORST.
KATHY,
YOU DID AN OKAY JOB
ON YOUR PHOTO SHOOT.
SOME OF THE JUDGES SAID
THEY SEE A PRETTY GIRL
IN THE HOMETOWN THAT'S CUTE,
BUT IN THE REAL WORLD
OF MODELING,
IT JUST DOESN'T MEASURE UP.
SO WHO GOES HOME--
THE GIRL WITH THE WORST PHOTO
IN THE BUNCH
OR THE GIRL
THAT SOME OF THE JUDGES
DON'T SEE TRUE POTENTIAL?
FURONDA.
♪♪♪
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
SO NOW INSTEAD OF THINKIN'
THAT YOU ROCKED IT,
YOU NEED TO KNOW
THAT RIGHT NOW,
YOU'RE AT THE BOTTOM
OF THIS HEAP,
BECAUSE WHAT YOU THINK IS RIGHT
IS SO WRONG.
BUT WE THINK
THAT YOU HAVE THE POTENTIAL
TO GROW AS A MODEL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, KATHY.
(crying)
♪♪♪
THANKS, YOU GUYS.
I'M VERY DISAPPOINTED.
I DID NOT WANT TO BE
THE FIRST TO GO HOME.
I FELT LIKE THIS WAS, MAYBE,
MY CHANCE TO SHINE,
BUT I GUESS NOT.
BUT, I MEAN, I GOT THIS FAR,
AND THIS IS PRETTY BIG.
I JUST WANT TO SAY
THIS ISN'T THE END.
YOU'LL BE SEEING ME.
I'M GONNA BE ON THE COVER
OF SOMETHING, SOMEDAY.
I'LL BE BIG.
JUST WAIT.
♪♪♪
STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
MAKEOVER DAY FINALLY ARRIVES--
TODAY IS A DAY
OF TRANSFORMATIONS.
AND JADE LOSES HER COOL.
ANTONIO WAS LIKE,
WE'RE GONNA CUT THIS SHORT
AND LEAVE THIS HIGH.
I THOUGHT THEY WERE
GONNA GIVE ME EXTENSIONS
BUT CHANGE MY COLOR.
AND THE HOUSE GAINS
A PRIMA DONNA.
DO YOU THINK YOU'RE QUEEN BEE
OF THE HOUSE?
THIS IS NOT
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP BEST FRIEND.
♪♪♪